the mouse wriggles desperately under the
cat's paw as the long curved feline
claws dig into its furry skin it squeaks
with the Primal Terror of a creature
that knows it's about to be devoured
alive no matter how hard it tries it
can't escape it's in the clutches of its
perfect Predator as the mouse fights for
its life the cat licks its fangs and
descends towards its frightened prey but
before it can sink its fangs into the
mouse's body the cat opens its mouth and
says sorry about this but I don't have a
choice in perfect English it started
with a man named Maurice whose
girlfriend was currently in the process
of dumping him the two of them sat in
the diner over cups of coffee and
mediocre eggs as she tried her best to
let him down gently but Maurice his eyes
glistening with tears didn't want to get
out that easy he asked his former
girlfriend Laura in case you were
interested
why she didn't want to be with him
anymore for reasons even she didn't
understand Laura decided that on that
fateful day she would be honest with the
man she was dumping she told him that he
is a nice guy he's just kind of boring
specifically he just isn't cultured he
only listens to Top 40 Music doesn't
watch any movies that don't have
superheroes in them she can't even
remember the most recent time she saw
him reading a book and never once in
their three-year relationship sh has she
ever seen him take an interest in art
Laura wishes Maurice a nice life and
leaves the diner the next couple of
weeks are hell for poor Maurice he
doesn't know what to do with himself in
the single life he goes to work but
that's about it the rest of the time he
cries he sleeps he eats whole buckets of
Ben & Jerry's and he rewatches the same
set of movies that Laura left him for
watching in the first place he's stuck
in a rut and endless loop and as he lays
on his couch in the dead of night while
Avengers Infinity War plays out on his
screen for the 21st time he notices how
blank his walls are bereft of even a
single poster photo or painting that's
when it hits him you call me uncultured
I'll show you Laura I can be plenty
cultured when I want to be that same
night he Googled art dealerships in his
area and found something interesting
Archibald's art and Antiquities on a
20-minute walk from his apartment the
place was apparently accredited with
sponsorships from something called MC
and d and also claiming to feature some
acclaimed pieces of Ann art from the
fine folks of the AWC Collective all of
this went over Maurice's not
particularly cultured head but he
decided he definitely be visiting the
place first thing in the morning when he
arrives after shaving and washing his
hair for the first time in over 2 weeks
he's feeling optim Mystic about his
prospects it is a classy looking store
the exact kind of thing he was expecting
when he read about the place online
there's even a handp painted open sign
in the front window the store owner
archbald presumably greets Maurice in
the doorway he's an old man with thick
black glasses and a white walking cane
is he blind Maurice is confused by that
a blind art dealer feels kind of like a
comedian who can't speak but the dealer
is polite and tells Maurice to look
around to his heart's content once again
Maurice feels a little out of his depth
on some level he knows Laura was right
he doesn't know the first thing about
art none of it was connecting his eyes
passed over paintings sculptures and
artistic photos with no effect he was
worried for a while that perhaps he was
truly hopeless until his eyes met with a
truly glorious sight a painting that
spoke to him on the very deepest levels
of his soul it doesn't even have a title
but the second he sees it he just knows
it has to be his it's a painting of a
fat cat lying against a pile of pillows
without a care in the world it's
everything that Maurice wants to be in
his life relaxed unbothered Carefree
happy before he even knows it he's
reaching for his wallet a short
transaction with archal later and
Maurice returned home with his new prize
possession a painting that represented a
turning point in his life in more ways
than he could have ever understood with
a hammer and some Nails he mounted the
precious painting up on his wall so that
he could look at it for inspiration
every single day it's the start of a new
chapter maybe everything would be better
now little did Maurice know the
transformation had already started 1
hour after initial viewing it's like a
switch in Maurice's brain had been
flipped he was suddenly pulled out of
his post breakup depressive slump
rejuvenated reborn with the painting up
on his wall he started to look at the
apartment differently this place was a
dump where was the life where was the
effort he needed to make the rest of the
apartment worth the Grandeur of the
painting he started cleaning up and
looking at articles on fun he carefully
rearranged the place until it looked
perfect like the kind of place a woman
would be proud to go back to speaking of
which he signed up for some old dating
profiles taking a nicer happier selfie
to to represent himself somehow with the
painting in his possession anything
seemed possible the possibilities were
endless for the first time in a long
time thoughts of Laura didn't even cross
his mind he's thinking about the future
rather than the past about all the
wonderful things that he can do and
experience now that he's single he's on
his way to being cultured one day after
initial viewing Maurice is picking up
some new tastes while spending hours
browsing ing online retailers like Etsy
and Redbubble he finds himself drawn to
furniture and ornaments around one
particular subject cats it doesn't even
really strike him as that strange at
first after all so many of the Articles
he read about interior decoration
advised having a cohesive theme for your
living space like a nice rug it just
really ties the room together he buys a
rug shaped like a cat he buys some cat
cushions and throw pillows a picture
frame with a cat on it cat charms cat
statues cat statuettes cat everything
the more he puts into his home the more
it feels like it's meant to be and
really why stop at just decoration he
starts buying t-shirts with cats on them
and sweaters with Kawaii cat faces
lovingly embroidered into the fabric he
even buys a woolly hat with cat ears on
top for when the winter months roll
around as the quantity of cat based
merchandise in his home begins to
outweigh everything else another thought
wanders into his mind there's not a no
pets clause in his lease agreement why
doesn't he just cut to the Chase and get
himself an actual pet cat with a sense
of joy and excitement he hasn't felt in
a long time he starts to Google local
rescues where he might be able to adopt
a new furry little friend one week after
initial viewing Maurice has already made
some of his dreams into a reality he's
got a Cat Felix who wanders around his
home he's thinking about getting another
as he pours some kibble into Felix's
bowl or maybe two others a whole family
of cuddly kitties to keep him company
why would he even need a girlfriend he
starts to think about how everyone would
be happier if they had a cat or two in
their life this is the thought that
inspires his new information campaign he
starts with the people at work telling
anyone who will listen to him about how
getting a cat has changed his life when
he does go on occasional dates his
favorite topic of conversation is of
course his feline friends he can't wait
to ask ask his potential Partners
whether they're cat people or dog people
and if they're undecided he eagerly
takes the opportunity to convert them it
didn't take long for his almost holy
mission to go further he wants to make
people's lives better and his life
started getting better when he first
bought that wonderful painting he tries
his best to convince people to come back
to his apartment just so they can take a
look at the painting most people
politely declined the offer 3 weeks
after initial viewing the changes to
Maurice's Behavior became a little more
drastic he's become so obsessed with the
feline lifestyle that his own behavior
begins to take on a kind of cat-like
Dimension he doesn't feel the need to
take a shower or bathe anymore why would
he need to when he can just lick himself
clean the same goes for eating why sit
at a table with a plate and a knife and
fork instead he eats directly off the
ground with his hands and mouth he
drinks milk out of a saucer hungrily
lapping it up some days he doesn't even
feel like walking bipedally he'll walk
on his hands and feet with his rear
sticking up in the air somehow it feels
more comfortable than walking normally
but the Transformations are only just
beginning 2 months after initial viewing
Maurice has started to notice that his
stubble is growing out faster than usual
sometimes he needs to shave twice a day
if he wants to stay neat but what began
with the stubble would soon grow quickly
out of proportion his eyebrows became
wild and bushy his hair started to
become almost a Mane growing out in
thick mutton chops and creeping down his
neck towards his back his arm and leg
hair the hair on his chest and his back
at a certain point shaving felt futile
he just let it grow out soon enough it
didn't look like hair it looked more
like well fur just like the soft silky
fur on his beloved Felix Maurice doesn't
mind it in fact he's starting to love it
with a cat in a room full of cat
memorabilia all overseen by his
beautiful perfect cat painting Maurice
fits right in here 4 months after
initial viewing Maurice woke up one
morning to find something strange about
himself even Stranger Than everything
else he's gotten smaller no it's not as
though he's lost weight he's physically
gotten smaller had Maurice been the kind
of guy who likes to habitually visit the
doctor they would have told him that his
skeletal structure had somehow
contracted along with his skin and
musculature nothing is out of proportion
it's almost like he's gradually been hit
with a kind of Science Fiction shrink
ray Maurice doesn't pay much mind to it
of course he only noticed that he gotten
shorter when he went to lovingly gaze at
his painting and noticed that he was
looking at it from a slightly different
angle than usual but that's fine much
like Maurice himself now it's snow
biggie if anything it's a real treat to
see his prized possession from a
slightly different perspective while
Maurice didn't know it at this point he
was only 2 months away from fully
completing the process he'd started
undergoing Just 4 months earlier 5
months after initial viewing the most
obvious of the changes started occurring
at this point for a few months now
people at the office had been politely
ignoring the peculiar changes to
Maurice's size and skin and his tendency
to treat lunch break very differently to
his colleagues but the alterations that
began at month 5 were impossible
possible to ignore first the ears they
disappeared against the sides of
Maurice's head instead two other ears
pointy and furry popped out of the top
of his skull half hidden amongst his
hair then came the eyes his sclera
disappeared and his pupils lengthened
and narrowed into black feline slits and
of course most inconvenient to Mar's
daily life the disappearances of his
thumbs and fingers they shortened down
to furry Nubs until his hands weren't
hands at all they were more like paw the
transformation is almost complete 6
months after initial viewing by now the
transformation is complete getting into
art has changed Maurice's life forever
he has now quite literally become a cat
he paused through his apartment with his
best friend Felix eating kibble to his
heart's content the one difference being
that Maurice despite his new form
retains all of his personality and mind
he can even talk if you're the kind of
person who enjoys talking to cats
because Maurice had the foresight to
leave a window open before the
transformation fully took hold he and
Felix could come and go as they pleased
when the kibble ran out they started
running through the alleys together
forging for scraps and hunting down mice
and birds for sustenance Maurice was
reported missing a month ago and there
have been no leads in the case posters
went up searches were performed but
nothing was ever never found a few
months after that he'd been declared
legally dead to the human world at least
Laura never thought about him again
after the news report stopped and
eventually his apartment was cleared out
and resold he and Felix would spend the
rest of their days eaing out a strange
little existence together on the streets
just taking it day by day and despite it
all Maurice is happy in case you somehow
hadn't gathered from all that SCP 3270
is an anomalous painting of a cat
lounging against a pillow isn't he
adorable you may be inclined to agree
but if you encounter the painting in
person that agreement may come at a
heavy cost while seeing secondary
reproductions of the painting has no
anomalous effect seeing the real thing
in person will cause horrific changes to
the human body little by little anyone
who observes the painting directly has a
considerable chance of turning into a
cat designated SCP
these are no ordinary cats of course
they're cats with human intelligence
human lifespans and even the ability to
speak despite CAD physiology not being
compatible with human speech the
painting itself is kept in site 64 and
any humans turned into cats by its
anomalous powers are kept in site 888
where they're very well taken care of
the idea of being turned into a cat and
forever forsaking your Humanity might
horrify you but you shouldn't worry
about it too much after all cats have it
pretty well roll up roll up Step Right
This Way ladies and gentlemen on the
other side of these canvas doors you're
about to witness something so monstrous
so hideous so repulsive that it will
turn your stomachs and fill you with
amazement the creature you'll find in
this tent has been known to elicit all
manner of responses from well-to-do
folks like yourselves you may want to
laugh at it you may want to strike it
down you may even want to throw rotten
fruit at it and believe you me we are
prepared for that you will find all
manner of Rotten Tomatoes eggs and other
festering foods that are begging to be
pelted for the low low price of 5 cents
per handful if you follow me through
these doors and gather around this cage
quietly perhaps you will see it wait for
your eyes to adjust to the dark and hold
your revulsion until you cannot bear it
anymore only then will we get to look at
the papery gray skin sagging loose over
a swollen gun
Marvel at its Tre trunk legs barely
strong enough to support its own weight
its deformed trunk that hangs limp off
the front of its face and its ridiculous
ears that flap nervously when it's
afraid don't be afraid of the Tusk
sticking out from its face or its cries
of pain and anguish instead hold your
tongues and wait for if you're patient
enough and perhaps with a slight beating
it may even play us a song with the
valves on its trunk then and only then
you're permitted to pel the Elephant Man
with whatever you see fit as you bask in
the glory of Herman Fuller's circus of
the disquieting ree Freeman didn't have
much of a choice but to join the circus
at the age of 14 the cast out son of a
freed slave in New Orleans he spent much
of his early life wandering the streets
trying not to get into any trouble in
the late 1800s very few places were
interested in hiring a young black man
unless of course they were looking to
turn him back to the life that his
father father had fought so hard to
escape that's why when Reese was out
fishing one afternoon and saw a big red
tent going up on the outskirts of town
he couldn't help but Wander Over much to
his surprise a group of black men were
the ones raising the Marquee they didn't
look like slaves either reys had never
heard of a circus the closest he'd ever
come to seeing was a traveling
entertainment cart that would sometimes
pop up around town with a dancing bear
in a cage or a glass ball in a pack of
tarot cards the brightly colored tents
that went up one after another were
enough to draw a crowd even the most
well-respected in New Orleans came out
for a look standing ankled deep in the
river Reese peered over at the man who
came out to address the throng dressed
in a long tail coat with a tall Top Hat
the man stood on a box of fruit and
waved a cane dramatically in the air
good folks of New Orleans what you're
about to witness tonight has never
before been seen this side of the
Mississippi wonders and amazement Galore
spectacle in intrig Mystery in Mayhem
and just a touch of the impossible I go
by the name of Herman Fuller the most
talented and notorious circus master in
the entire United States the dazzling
array of shows that I've brought before
you is not for the faint of heart or the
weak of constitution your stomachs will
be turned and your minds may be altered
but it promises to be a knight that you
will never forget Reese wasn't much
interested in any of what he had just
said this kind of Two Penny show was
reserved for the folks who had the money
to throw around on needless things like
smiling and having a nice evening what
Reese was far more interested in were
the groups of men working behind the
scenes pulling various carts and setting
up all of the Stalls a lot of them
didn't look much older than him a grin
spread across his face SCP 4409 insisted
on being interviewed in the dark with
all the lights in the interview chamber
Switched Off Dr Simon Crossley entered
the room and sat down across from the
Elephant Man even in the dim light
though he was able to still make out
part of the man's features the ivory
tusks the hanging nose and the nervously
twitching ears the man had been picked
up in St Louis where local police had
found him panhandling in the streets
while he certainly seemed harmless
enough it was important for the
foundation to take him in just to be
sure sitting in the dark interview room
Ree Freeman was apprehensive at first
about telling his side of the story a
life of being mocked spat on and chased
out of towns had left him with a real
distrust of other people that was
probably made worse by his apprehension
at being put in another cage within the
foundation he told Dr Crossley that he
was born as normal as could be that his
current ghastly Affliction was something
done to him quite some time ago but as
much as it pained him to recollect it
was a tale that he knew he'd probably
have to tell Dr Crossley replied that he
was all ears it took Dr Crossley a few
seconds to realize his faux paw as CP
4409 glared at him before continuing to
explain how he was made the way he was
reys Freeman had managed to land a job
with the circus surprisingly easily
despite having no previous experience
and no references to back him up Herman
Fuller took a shine to him it was menial
work and not many folks were up to doing
it but since reys had never had a job
before he didn't know any better he
started out at the bottom of the ladder
scraping out feces washing down old
cages and carrying heavy crates the one
scrawny 14-year-old boy quickly turned
into a stocky 17-year-old with broad
shoulders and strong legs they would
travel from town to town across most of
the United States stopping off in major
cities for weeks at a time to bring in
as much money as possible before moving
on Reese didn't save much of that money
but he didn't mind the fact that he got
too meals a day and something to do with
himself was enough in fact he kind of
enjoyed sleeping on top of the carts as
the horses pulled them across the dusty
American roads the one thing that always
seemed to affect him though was that he
was never allowed to actually see inside
the tents he would see folks come and go
through the canvas doors week after week
but was never allowed so much as a peak
inside himself the older guys were
responsible for throwing the canvas
sheets over the cages which would remain
that way as they traveled not having
seen much of the world at that point
Reese didn't have much of an idea of
what could be in those cages perhaps
some kind of animal from a foreign
country something from Africa or Asia
they made all kinds of noise Reese said
that most of them sounded like humans
but then they'd go and make strange
animal sounds that no human mouth could
ever produce one night his curiosity got
the better of him hanging back before
the crowds got into the tent he Sid
stepped over to the entrance making sure
that no one saw saw him and took a peek
through the doorway it was dark inside
too dark to make out much of what was
happening the crowd of people was
standing between him and the cage all
jostling and leaning this way and that
trying to make out whatever it was that
was inside a screeching sound filled the
air making the whole crowd and Reese
outside jump right standing on his
tiptoes he tried his best to see what
was moving around in that cage it seemed
to be moving around like a person
lurching this way and that but the
sounds coming from it sounded more like
a bird and sure enough after a moment a
huge pair of disproportionately ugly
Wings stretched out from either side of
the creature flapping and sending a rush
of air through the tent so powerful that
it blew the flap wide open in front of
him just as Herman Fuller turned around
to see him standing there ree bolted and
hid behind one of the carts he was going
to be in trouble for this he was sure of
it it was one of Fuller's only rules of
the circus and he had just gone and
broken it he was in the hottest water
imaginable but as nighttime fell and the
drags of the spectators wandered out of
the tent Fuller seemed to be in too bad
a mood at all watching him from a
distance reys got the impression that he
might not actually be in as much trouble
as he thought Fuller caught his eye and
came over cane twirling and Top Hat
sitting jauntily at top his head Reese
got off on the wrong foot apologizing
right away for spying into the tent the
circus Master just laughed it off and
slapped him on the back Reese my boy
don't worry about it I've got much
bigger plans for you much much bigger
that night as Reese lay in bed he had a
terrible dream about what he had seen in
the tent that day circus of the
disquieting was certainly an apt title
for this place the image of that strange
shadowy bird person in the cage haunted
his nightmares until suddenly two pairs
of strong hands gripped him and ripped
him out of his sleep he knew better than
to fight back this was surely going to
be his comeuppance for breaking Fuller's
rules earlier they dragged him into the
main tent where there was an oil lamp in
the middle Illuminating what looked like
a heavy wooden operating table his
wrists and ankles were strapped in and
then the two men left him alone he had
half a mind to scream but with all the
Caged up creatures from the circus
around him he doubted anyone would pay
him much mind it was almost an hour
before Herman Fuller walked into the
tent by this point Reese expected
expected him to be walking in with
surgical equipment gloves maybe even a
saw but the man had nothing in his bare
hands Herman Fuller asked him if he ever
heard of Joseph Merrick Reese didn't
answer of course he had heard of the
Elephant Man the whole world had been
talking about Joseph Merrick for months
a man born so hideously deformed that
people had compared him to an elephant
though the resemblance wasn't that
convincing this sentiment was clearly
shared by Fuller who placed one hand on
either side of Reese's face and began to
softly massage his cheeks explaining how
disappointed he was that merik didn't
actually look all that much like an
elephant Reese's cheeks started to hurt
as the man massaged him almost as if he
was stretching and pulling at his face
finding loose skin the boy asked Fuller
what he was doing the circus Master just
smiled at him and explained that it was
an old technique handed down in his
family a gift he called it he started
touching Reese's nose nose gently
pulling at it with more and more
pressure much to ree's surprise he felt
his nose elongating growing longer and
longer in the man's hand he tried to
Twitch his face and was starting to find
that his new nose twitched along with it
the longer it grew the more painful it
felt the skin and flesh from his head
being ripped and pulled into a new shape
at several points Reese felt ready to
pass out from the agony but the circus
Master kept talking to him kept him
awake through the whole ordeal as he
molded the boy's face like clay into the
shape of an elephant lying on the bench
panting reys could see his trunk from
between his two eyes it was a nightmare
that was all it was but then Fuller
reached under the workbench and lifted
out a small hand drill one by one he
punched holes into the top of Reese's
trunk installing little valves like a
trumpet as he went standing back to
admire his handiwork he told Reese that
he would be his new favorite traction my
boy I have made you into a star the
tusks did not come straight away over
the course of several months they slowly
and painfully emerged from his deformed
jaw his elephantine legs were also not
part of his initial transformation but
instead came as a result of health
issues he developed while being trapped
in a cage for several decades crowds of
people would come and go flocking to see
the Elephant Man having spent SP the
first part of his life constantly hungry
Reese was now being overfed every day
hands would come to his cage and force
him to eat Rich fatty foods denying him
any possibility of exercise the broad
shoulders and strong legs that he had
developed while working at the circus
melted away under layers and layers of
fat his skin went gray and papery
folding and wrinkling in on itself
either from Fuller's magic or just from
a lack of sunlight whatever it was with
every passing day reys Freeman steadily
became more and more hideous SCP 4409
was stuck in the circus for much of his
life eventually Herman Fuller moved on
and is currently being hunted by the SCP
Foundation when he did SCP 4409 was able
to bargain for its freedom from the
circus wandering from City to City never
sticking around for very long SCP 449
begged for change at the side of the
road some people would feel sympathy
While most would feel horror at its
disfigurement from its years trapped in
a cage SCP 4409 has developed severe
health issues including gout severe
obesity and metabolic syndrome while in
Foundation custody it is fed a special
diet to counteract these conditions as
of yet the foundation has no way of
reversing what was done to Reese Freeman
in the tent in the 1800s as Reese poses
no threat to the foundation he is
allowed to live with relative Freedom or
at least as much Freedom as a contained
CP can earn his health condition
severely limits his Mobility around site
66 a low security residential
containment area unable to walk even
moderate distances SCP 4409 heavily
relies on the use of a cane and a
heavyduty walker capable of supporting
up to 140 kg researchers listen intently
at his door waiting to hear if he's ever
going to play a sad song on his trumpet
but no sound ever emerges except for his
heavy breathing and splutter in coughs
it appears that having spent decades
locked in a small cage a sedentary life
is all he knows now with every
opportunity to exercise read books and
take up new hobbies SCP 4409 appears
unable to engage with anything other
than sitting and staring at the same
spot on the wall every day if an animal
has spent its whole life living in a zoo
and finds in its old age that one of the
walls has fallen down what use has it in
taking a step outside side a d-class
prisoner enters the chamber it is quiet
save for the subtle whipping sounds
coming from a bizarre shape in the
middle of the room upon closer
inspection it becomes clear that the
floating object isn't one entity but a
mass of smaller objects all floating and
thrashing in the air their ammunition of
various calibers and sizes spinning
around in a spherical form the d-class
becomes nervous but is ordered to
proceed by Foundation Personnel slowly
inch by anxious inch he advances closer
towards the mass of bullets his heart
knocks harder against his chest with
every step he takes the thumping begins
to deafen his ears he could feel his
throat tightening up as the blood rushes
to his head and sweat starts to form on
his brow the sound of the thrashing gets
louder with legs trembling and
fingertips numbing the declass opens his
mouth in an attempt to let in a gasp of
air to calm his nerves but before before
he could even take a full breath and in
the blink of an eye countless bullets
suddenly burst forth from the mass
spraying the d-class relentlessly with
ammunition and killing him instantly the
foundation Personnel watching this from
safety note down the events as they
Ponder the question why does this mass
of living ammunition act so volatile why
are some able to approach it safely
While others are killed what is the
secret of SCP
577 classified as uclid SCP 577 began as
one of the most mysterious objects in
Foundation custody an animated mass of
ammunition those who are able to get
close enough to it observe that the
plurality of bullets inside were 9 mm
accompanied by a selection of 10 mm and
45 caliber rounds the bullets are
normally calm moving in predictable
patterns and occasionally Shifting the
mass to reflect other shapes including
cats and dogs but something else about
the mass concerns the foundation more
and more the mass is is growing it is
dramatically larger than it was when it
was first acquired by the foundation and
it seems to be adding approximately
1,000 bullets per year this raises the
question can it be contained permanently
currently it is held in a standard large
containment unit but its quarters have
been reinforced with the foundation's
best steel blast shielding due to the
danger to anyone who opens the door the
entire facility is handled with remote
technology and can only be opened by
approved Personnel but someone needs
needs to check that everything is stable
the foundation learned the hard way that
entering the containment unit was a bad
idea any foundation staff ranging from a
highlevel scientist to a standard
security officer is met with immediate
hostility from SCP 577 massive bullets
the second they approach The Entity the
bullets shoot out from the mass with
speed of a standard handgun aiming
directly at their target this indicates
that SCP 577 is intelligent it is
capable of seeing and reacting and it
hates Foundation personnel with a
passion fortunately the foundation
doesn't have to sacrifice its permanent
staff SCP 577 is not the first entity to
react with hostility towards its captors
after all few of the specimens are happy
to be permanently contained in Secure
facilities so it was determined that
d-class Personnel would be sent into the
facility twice a year to inspect it for
any damage making sure the entity was
still secure and test SCP 577 reaction
to the presence of different people not
from the foundation staff and that's
where things got interesting many of the
d-class Personnel didn't trigger the
entity at all resulting in neutral
behavior however those d-class who were
initially Foundation staff and demoted
due to Broken policy were met with the
same hostility as current staff
indicating that SCP 577 was not going to
be fooled easily the same happened with
some d-class with a specific background
it was immediately sprayed with a
violent hail of bullets causing injury
or death upon investigation every single
one of those d-class was revealed to
previously be a member of law
enforcement however some d-class
Personnel were met with a very different
reaction these people were the most
likely to see the other side of SCP 577
when it reduced its hostile stance and
instead took on a friendly form
appearing as a dog or cat it would even
approach the d-class in a welcoming
manner
this was most likely to happen when the
d-class was formerly homeless or had
spent time in the prison system but one
incident brought SCP 577 true nature
into a new light d2812 6 was the latest
unfortunate conscript to be sent into
SCP 577 chamber for an annual cleaning
and inspection his duties were simple
including to inspect the walls for
damage clean out any stray material left
around by the bullets firing as well as
any corpses that were left behind and
make any needed repairs to the walls he
would be wearing protective gear but
that wasn't always enough to protect
someone from the hail of bullets and no
one knew exactly how the volatile mass
of bullets would react but from the
second the d-class entered it was clear
that this would be a very different
encounter as soon as d2812 6 entered SCP
577 seemed to take on a friendly posture
it shape shifted into the form of a
large cat and would freak ly approached
the d-class while he was cleaning the
d-class was confused at first but suum
seemed to appreciate the company he
would occasionally stop cleaning to pet
the cat made out of bullets but as the
work went on he seemed to slow down he
appeared to be crying and eventually he
stopped working entirely and slumped
against the wall the foundation
attempted communication with him but the
d-class didn't respond soon SCP 577
joined him against the wall and the
d-class held him his his hand was guided
into the mass of bullets and it soon
emerged holding a single bullet the
d-class held the strange entity for a
few more minutes before the staff's
insistence that he exit the chamber grew
stronger he eventually left and the
foundation took him back into custody
and examined the bullet he was holding
it was not a normal bullet the bullet
was moving almost as if it was a beating
heart as it throbbed up and down upon
closer inspection it was revealed to be
covered with blood but d2812 six had not
been hit by the bullet he was completely
uninjured but when he emerged from the
chamber his hand was covered in blood
exactly where he had inserted it into
the mass of bullets the bullet was sent
to SCP facilities for testing the blood
was not a match for D
28126 but it was genetically similar
like a relative the d-class was brought
back into the interrogation chamber and
the bullet was returned to him he was
apparently linked to SCP 577 somehow and
identified himself by his name uro roas
his interviewer Dr Vanderbilt asked him
to explain what happened and Arturo
explained that the mass of bullets
didn't just turn into a cat it turned
into a cat he knew as a child which had
a uniquely shaped tail that he would
recognize anywhere the cat that was once
helped by uro and his brother uro was
questioned why he quit working and began
crying and revealed that he heard the
massive bullets say something barely
audible SCP 577 had whispered I'm sorry
but what would a cat have to be sorry
for aruro became angry when Dr
Vanderbilt questioned this but Dr
Vanderbilt continued and conceded that
aruro recognized the cat somehow he
proded Arturo to share the rest of his
story and Arturo eventually revealed the
root of his bond to SCP
577 aruro and his deaf brother Ricardo
were homeless at a young age after their
mother threw them out while they were
living on the streets they met a cat
that they gave a little of their food to
from time to time the little cat became
their constant companion they named him
duck after Arturo's brother's favorite
sign language gesture but tragedy was
just around the corner duck and Ricardo
were inseparable with the little cat
essentially becoming a therapy pet to
the boy but one day Ricardo encountered
a police officer the deaf boy couldn't
understand the officer's orders and the
officer didn't know or didn't bother to
use sign language ultimately bullets
were fired Ricardo was killed another
unarmed young man killed in a police
shooting and duck was left alone but the
cat had one more job to do he had led
aruro back to his brother the area was
swarming with police and Arturo never
got a chance to say goodbye he lashed
out at the only one he could duck the
cat tried to comfort his surviving
person but Arturo threw rocks at the cat
and chased him away he never saw the cat
again and was left alone with his grief
he saw in the news days later that the
officer was cleared in the shooting his
brother was blamed for threatening the
officer and the News implied that
Ricardo was a gang member aruro was left
without closure until SCP 577 entered
the picture Dr Vanderbilt expressed his
sympathies but wasn't sure what any of
this had to do with the entity aroto
explained further why he started crying
when he felt the pulsating bullet he
spent years sleeping next to Ricardo and
he recognized his brother's heartbeat
the bullet was his brother's heart or at
least contained his Essence and for the
first time in 10 years aruro was able to
make peace not just with the cat he had
rejected out of grief but with the
brother he had lost far too long the
foundation had answers but they only led
to more questions aruro had pulled a
single bullet out of the massive SCP 577
and it was the one containing his
brother's heart was this the bull bullet
that killed Ricardo was every bullet in
the mass one that killed a person was
the mass growing with every new death
and if that was the case did the mass
contain the memory and pain of every
life a bullet took if so that would
explain the compassion The Entity seems
to hold for those who had been homeless
or imprisoned as well as its intense
hostility for any sort of law
enforcement figure for now SCP 577
remains stable and contained within its
unit needing only standard upkeep of its
cell to avoid any breaches but as it
continues to grow Foundation authorities
worry that it may get strong enough to
eventually breach containment but this
is a tricky case for the foundation the
entity's growth is out of their control
and nothing they've done to date has
stopped or slowed it in any way it seems
something on the outside is making it
grow and shows no sign of slowing down
anytime soon who doesn't love dogs
they're friendly energetic and can be
beneficial to their owner's happiness
and mental health on top of all those
positive qualities most dogs are
fiercely loyal to their masters you'll
often hear stories of dogs defending
their owners or even staying by their
side through their very last days and
even sticking next to them Beyond Death
as sad as that thought might be to many
dog owners it provides us the perfect
context for today's topic it's about
time you met SCP
1111 sometimes also known by the
nickname the white dog this moniker
actually refers to one of the two halves
of SCP 1111 namely the former SCP 111
11-1 while its counterpart is simply
known only as SCP 111
11-2 as you may have already deduced SCP
11-11-1 is or at least appears to be a
fairly common domesticated dog sporting
white fur that gives it its nickname the
white dog is a cross between two
different popular breeds the German
Shepherd and the labrador retriever
however upon closer inspection this
particular pup is a far cry from one you
might see fetching sticks or chasing
squirrels at the park for one this dog
never eats or drinks under normal
circumstances that would be worrying
behavior in any dog but in SCP 1111 d1's
case it comes second to the fact that
this dog is partially seethrough now
that's definitely not normal in actual
fact this Pooch is pretty far from
ordinary it seems to be at least
semi-translucent not quite as much as we
usually picture a ghost or hologram but
also not fully visible like a living
being in fact how clearly visible the
white dog is can vary depending on how
close it is to 111
11-2 any further than 500 M away and the
dog will gradually grow more and more
transparent but not fully invisible but
visibility isn't the only thing that
shifts with 111 11 d1's distance from
its other half the size of the dog also
changes it remains standing at 150 CM
when directly beneath 1111 D2 and
gradually gets smaller the further and
further away from 111 11-2 it gets
finally there's its eyes SCP 111 11-1
possesses a distinct pair of glowing red
eyes the brightness and intensity of
which increase the closer it is to 111
11-2 so let's recap so far we have a
strange white dog with glowing eyes that
changes size and becomes more or less
visible the further it gets from a
secondary element but if the white dog
is SCP 111 11-1 then what forms this
second part of SCP 1111 well if you were
to look close enough at the white dog
you'd notice the red collar that it
wears around its neck and hanging from
that collar is a tag on which is printed
one single word loyal it's certainly A
fitting word to describe
11-11-1 why because SCP 1111 D2 is
presumably the dog's master or rather
its Master's dead body dressed in an old
worn business suit and formal dress
shoes SCP 111 11-2 appears to be a
deceased male of indeterminate age the
precise identity of this man has proven
next to impossible for foundation
researchers to determine the condition
of his suit and shoes have deteriorated
so much that it has been difficult ult
to even identify the original company
that produced the clothing worn by the
corpse as for his cause of death well
that unfortunately seems all too obvious
given that the 111 11-2 body always
appears the same way hanging from a tree
with a noose around his neck Foundation
staff observed the two parts that make
up SCP 1111 have noted that 111 11-2
will occasionally make quick violent
twitching movements these random jerks
and spasms of the corpse are consistent
with with those exhibited by a person
who is dying from asphixiation and often
researchers have heard the body making
desperate gasps for air the closer his
white fured canine counterpart is the
more frequent and violent these motions
and sounds will become it's almost as if
SCP 111 11-2 has somehow been trapped on
the very brink of death reliving those
final moments over and over again all
while guarded by his loyal white dog if
left alone and not interfered with the
white dog will lie down just beneath
where its Master's body is hanging the
dog never sleeps nor does it require any
food or water and does not even seem to
breathe and as long as Foundation
research staff keep their distance both
parts of SCP 1111 seem content to remain
in a docile state to keep them contained
the SCP Foundation has established a 2
km safe Zone around SCP 1111 keeping
them monitored through cameras attached
to weather balloons the restricted encl
closure is according to a public cover
story a weather monitoring station hence
the balloons no member of foundation
staff is permitted anywhere within a
kilometer of SCP 1111 unless they are
given express permission from a superior
member of the foundation should SCP
11-11-1 ever stray away from the tree
where its Master hangs though then the
area must be evacuated of all Personnel
until the dog returns to its normal
position however Foundation staff are
urged to be wary When approaching SCP
1111 because the white dog may well be
more ferociously loyal than any pet
emphasis on ferocious the moment that
11-11-1 becomes aware of anything coming
towards itself and its owner's body the
dog will become viciously hostile
regardless of the person or object
coming towards it the semic corporeal
canine will attempt to attack and
destroy the Intruder in this state the
white dog exhibits even more dramatic
physiological differences from a normal
domesticated dog dog video footage
recorded by the SCP Foundation shows
that the dog is capable of reaching
incredible speeds of up to 60 km per
hour which is of course considerably
faster than an average canine the white
dog can also reach a height of 6 M When
jumping up into the air and as teeth and
a bite strength powerful enough to tear
through armor plating composed of 15 mm
thick titanium given the entity's speed
aggression and translucent qualities any
attempts by the SCP Foundation to
neutralize the white dog or even capture
it for closer examination have ended the
same Grizzly way for the staff members
who tried the creature's Fierce loyalty
defending its owner's body also make it
incredibly difficult for foundation
staff to even get close enough to SCP
111 11-2 to properly study the remains
as we said before that loyal tag around
the dog's neck is certainly an accurate
description on a date which has been
redacted from its file an incident
occurred involving SCP 1111 and a team
that consisted of a number of foundation
agents this team had been ordered to
neutralize the white dog and transport
the anomalous animal to a containment
facility attempting to evade the
creature's direct line of sight the
agents approached the hanging body of
SCP 111 11-2 from the north the opposite
direction to the way the dog was facing
possessing a sense of hearing and smell
far beyond that of a human being the
white dog was able to quickly detect the
agents approaching its master when the
team got within 300 M of the tree where
the body was hanging the canine set upon
them tearing at clothing and shredding
protective armor with its teeth in order
to get the agent soft flesh underneath
one of these agents fled running as fast
as they could from the area but of
course this was audile move as the white
dog quickly noticed and began to pursue
the foundation agent with its
superpowered speed as it chased them the
surveillance cameras recorded SCP
11-11-1 decreasing in size becoming
harder to see with the naked eye the
further it ran from the tree the dog's
speed began to decline too the further
the dog got from the tree with the Noose
the less the body hanging from it seemed
to be spasming too when the white dog
had reached 900 M from SCP 11 11-2 the
corpse was seen to stop moving entirely
Frozen and stiff as one would normally
expect a de cease body to be realizing
how far away it was from its Master SCP
11-11-1 froze a hearing unsure for a
moment it turned to look towards the
body of its Master perhaps sensing that
the random jerks and postmortem
movements had stopped at this point the
dog howled and sprinted back towards the
tree causing the corpse of its owner to
begin twitching yet again footage of
this incident showed that the white dog
was impervious to Conventional Weapons
and any rounds fired at the canine by
Foundation agents merely passed through
its ghostly body however its claws and
teeth were very much solid and it was
able to slaughter a almost all the
agents save for the one who fled who
ended up being the sole survivor of the
encounter following this disastrous
Mission the 05 Council issued an order
that in order to protect the lives of
foundation personnel only remote control
drones and Expendable d-class Personnel
would be permitted anywhere near SCP
1111 shortly after the previous incident
a group of d-class were sent into the
area around the tree where SCP 111 11-2
was hanging this time approaching from
multiple Direction at once but this only
led to the same results as the white dog
began to quickly move between each of
the DCL classes killing them one after
another only one D
83011 was able to make it close enough
to the corpse to make any noteworthy
observations as they approached the
hanging corpse of SCP 111 11-2 seemed to
slow its jerks and twitches and the body
did something that had never been seen
before it opened its eyes it raised its
arms toward towards the approaching
d-class in what looked like a welcoming
hug only for D
83011 to be torn to shreds by the white
dog moments after cameras nearby picked
up more previously unseen movement
namely the owner's mouth moving almost
as if he was saying the words no down
boy but soon after the corpse fell limp
again and resumed its normal Twitches
following this the foundation have
theorized that the white dog could
possibly be contained by somehow
removing its Master's body from the area
some staff have also noted that SCP 1111
shares certain traits with SCP 023 a
similar anomalous creature also referred
to as the black Shu much like the white
dog the Shu also possesses a ghostly
canine form and appears to be the same
large doglike creature that is
referenced in ancient folklore from
throughout the British Isles according
to Legend the shuck appears to Travelers
at Crossroads serving as an omen of bad
luck impending disaster and is even
thought to be one of the hounds of Hell
itself SCP 023 like SCP 1111 also has
anomalous abilities that focus on
Geographic space in the black Shuck's
case anyone it detects approaching it
will die or lose a member of their
family within a year researchers working
for the foundation believe that SCP 023
and SCP 11-11-1 could be related or even
instances of the same phenomenon a sort
of dog yin and yang but since they have
still as of yet been unable to capture
the white dog it has been impossible to
verify this the SCP Foundation will no
doubt keep trying though while testing
may have been suspended for the time
being they always know where to find SCP
111 11-1 beneath its Master's hanging
body guarding it for all eternity to
paraphrase noted scientist Dr Hines
doofen Schurz if I had a nickel for
every time there was a safe class
anomaly that manifests an absurdly long
entity that stuck on the ground and pops
up at multiple points around the world
and have two nickel which isn't a lot
but it's weird that it's happened twice
incidentally that happens to be the case
with SCP 1193 the bur Giant and SCP
2952 Corgi they're a pair of mysterious
creatures with very thought-provoking
similarities between them but while both
are exceedingly long entities neither
are particularly long stories So today
we're giving you a rare SCP explained
anomaly double feature let's begin with
the first of our two very long boys SCP
1193 the exact nature of SCP 1193 is
anomalous qualities are challenging to
Define it appears to have biological
spatial and even temporal elements SCP
11193 d01 the primary component of SCP
1193 is a human arm that appears
completely normal in a genetic sense but
exhibits a freakish length and bone
structure this absurdly long arm was
first discovered in a drainage pipe
inside the basement of a telephone
switching station in Scottdale Arizona
where it had somehow become trapped how
this anomaly was first discovered or by
whom is not recorded approximately 10 cm
below the drainage gate of the pipe the
arm terminates in what seems to be a
human hand of indeterminate gender that
is unremarkable in both size and
structure upon initial examination the
foundation believed that the arm somehow
threaded through 35 M of drainage pipe
but the use of an endoscop a camera
within the pipe revealed that the
reality is much more severe the arm
extends to at least 71 km beneath the
Earth which is around double the overall
length of Scottdale Arizona itself with
elbows regularly spaced across every 4
km of arm elbows below a depth of 26 km
are slightly retroflex to accommodate a
9° Southward Bend in the drainage bore
hole interestingly the arm was also
somehow able to pass through the
morovich discontinuity which is the
lower limit of the Earth's crust and the
volcanic hot upper mantle the arm could
actually be longer than what we're
currently aware but the foundation
doesn't have any technology Hardy enough
to follow the arm all the way down into
the Earth conversations that Foundation
staff have had with what is believed to
be SCP
11931 via the use of SCP 1193 d02
indicates that the entity may have no
Thermo reception it has described itself
as being stuck in environments that
contextually should have either
extremely high or extremely low
temperatures this does not seem to
register with SCP
11931 this may serve as an explanation
as to why it is experiencing no
discomfort despite the Bold temperatures
having been measured in excess of 674 de
Centigrade but what exactly is SCP 1193
d02 SCP
11932 is a gopo 746 rotary telephone
with a topaz yellow plastic exterior
manufactured in
1971 because of the physical dimensions
of the phone it is too large to have
been delivered from below via the bore
hole so we know that SCP
11931 didn't put it there the working
theory of foundation researchers
assigned to the 1193 case is that the
phone was installed here specifically to
facilitate Communications with the
trapped SCP 1193 d01 it is attached to a
conventional twisted pair line which
enters the drainage pipe containing SCP
93-01 and ascends parallel to SCP
11931 until endoscopy is no longer
practical who or what installed the
phone how and to what end Beyond just
chatting with the entity the foundation
doesn't presently no and the
investigation is ongoing one clue to the
purpose of SCP
11932 is the fact that its rotary dial
has been permanently glued in place
rendering it unusable for any kind of
outgoing call
instead the phone only receives calls
and the only calls it seems to receive
are from a being that seems to be SC SCP
1193 d01 every weekday between 8:32 a.m.
and 10:34 p.m. mountain standard time
the phone will ring up to five times
when answered by a member of foundation
Personnel an unidentified voice believed
to be that of SCP
11931 will willingly engage in
conversation with the person on the
other end of the line the foundation has
used this opportunity to question SCP
11931 about its own nature but it's
impossible to really know how reliable
the entity's answers are the voice on
the line always refers to itself as a
human being and often mistakes the
foundation Personnel for authority
figures such as doctors firemen or
police as a result of this The Voice has
been forthcoming with information and
the interviews have been relatively
straightforward there have been notable
similarities between the information
that the voice voluntarily gives about
itself and the known facts about the
condition of SCP
11931 lending credibility to the idea
that they are one and the same the
foundation fastidiously records
conversations with the voice and has
created a list of anomalous details The
Entity has surrendered during the phone
calls these include having human
features but an anomalous body plan so
the voice seems to have all the right
pieces for a human being but in a
bizarre configuration this may explain
the extremely long many jointed arm
whatever species or subspecies this
entity is it may not be alone as the
voice often refers to a cousin or some
kind of other relative who's on the way
to pick it up the voice often talks
about its feelings of discomfort or
boredom at its state of being confined
it also makes reference to strange
seismic activity along the little Chino
fault complex an upper branch of the
Elenor fault zone of Southern California
over 300 M away from Arizona this may be
because the source of the voice is is so
far underground it's still able to feel
the Tremors resonating upwards but one
of the most frequent trends of all in
these conversations is that the voice
venting frustration that its arm or some
other body part is stuck in An
Inconvenient place this list of places
has been exhaustive but includes
handcuffs a jelly jar a pipe a cast or
in one instance a gopher hole naturally
this has been seen as a cause for
concern among Foundation staff if SCP
1193 does have spatially Ness components
is it possible that someone could find a
70 km arm sticking out of a gopher hole
or a jelly jar sometime soon only time
will tell the foundation currently
regards any information about the
physical form of the entity beyond the
exposed section of the arm reached via
endoscopy as provisional in other words
they really have no idea what they're
dealing with here and are unlikely to
find out for sure any time soon two
phone conversations with The Voice via
SCP
11932 have been transcribed in the
addendum to 1193 is main file both are
conversations between the voice and Dr
Hassan IAL director of research at the
local SCP Containment site in the first
of two conversations recorded on March
24th 2008 Dr ibal asked who was calling
and the voice identified itself as David
The Voice or David appeared to be in its
usual state of frustration and distress
incorrectly believing that Dr ibal was a
medical doctor at the hospital he was
currently trapped in inside David
implored him to remove the cast from his
bottom arm when Dr ibal questioned David
on what exactly a bottom arm is he
responded with confusion when Dr ikbal
told him that he was a research
scientist not a medical doctor David
became frustrated implied that Dr ibal
was incompetent and hung up the next
recorded call between Dr ibal and the
voice occurred exactly a year later in
this call The Voice incorrectly believed
that Dr ibal was a fireman The Voice
complained about having reached into its
oven to pull out some cakes becoming
stuck in the process he pleaded for help
saying that the oven was a tight fit
when Dr IAL showed concern about the
potentially high temperatures within the
oven the voice didn't seem to know what
he meant in the end the voice became
frustrated and resolved to instead call
its Cousin It apologized and hung up
most calls appear to follow this General
structure because of the static and
Incredibly subdued nature of the anomaly
the foundation has deemed that SCP 1193
poses no meaningful risk of containment
breach as a result it has been given the
rare safe classification in order to
keep it properly contained the drainage
bore hole containing SCP 1193 d01 is
capped with a Tungsten steel grate
containing a locking 2.5 cm endoscopy
aperture meaning a small hole through
which to feed the endoscopic camera
every 48 Hours the drainage bore hole is
inspected with an endoscope for any
further developments concerning the
anomalous arm seism traffic monitoring
devices are posted at 2 7 and 11 km
depths alongside the SCP
11931 bore hole seismic readings
consistent with a Subterranean movement
are reported immediately to site
director ikbal in the event of what is
referred to as Subterranean Containment
Breach researchers and guards working
around 1193 are ordered to perform
protocol
473a this involves severing SCP 1193
below the fifth elbow and back filling
remaining portions of the bore hole with
pressurized concrete to seal the hole
forever the SCP 1193 d02 phone is
monitored at all times by a train
Foundation interrogator and standard
procedure dictates that SCP 1193 d02 is
to be answered on or before the third
ring during these calls the interrogator
will attempt to elicit valuable
information about SCP 1193 from The
Voice and all valuable Intel will then
be recorded and logged the burri giant
is one of the more perplexing safe CL
class anomalies handled by the SCP
Foundation so much about its true nature
is unknown to this day but a concern
that both we and the foundation share is
not knowing where the entity's other
limbs are currently residing for all we
know they could be sticking out of an
oven a Gover hole or even a jelly jar
somewhere near you weird right well if
you think that's strange let us now
introduce you to SCP
2952 or Corgi trust us if you're not
familiar with this one already you are
not ready for the strange turns this is
about to take in the simplest terms
Corgi is a cheerful Welsh pemer Corgi
with an adorable face and a thick shiny
coat he's also over 30,000 km in length
with his head and front legs sticking
out of the ground in Portland Oregon and
his hindquarters being all the way over
in a rural area of Japan's kadawa
District his body weaves all across the
globe with sections of it surfacing all
over the Americas Europe and much of
Asia studies to find African or a
Australian sections of SCP 2952 are
still ongoing despite his massive length
there seems to be no delay in reaction
times either you Pat his head in the USA
and his tail will immediately start
wagging over in Japan he's honestly just
precious he also doesn't appear to need
food or water and thanks to the somewhat
sadistic experiments of one researcher
Mills we know that he can quickly
regenerate from all Damage Done to him
too okay now you're familiar with this
very good albeit very long lad it's time
for things to get really really strange
you see on the different exposed section
of SCP 2952 is body there are tiny
openings designated SCP
29521 stay with us here there are 324
openings all over the world some in
major cities others in Suburban areas
some in the tiniest and most rural of
hamlets at this point you probably have
the very reasonable question why are
there over 300 openings in this dog well
we're going to answer answer that but we
can't promise it won't just give you
more confusing questions when the
openings appear humanoid beings
designated SCP 29 52-2 will begin to
exit the Corgi for the sake of clarity
we'll refer to these little creatures as
the Welsh Fair folk or the Fay though
there are many different subgroups of
Fay and we really do mean little in this
case on average they're a puny 3 cm tall
and they're also invisible to the naked
eye with indirect methods like
photographs or videos being the only way
to view them though they do leave
evidence of their presence beyond their
direct physical appearances like Shadows
or Footprints Corgi acts as a kind of
transport system for these little people
openings on the dextrous side of SCP
2952 take passengers West while those on
the sinistrous side take passengers East
passengers can be seen entering and
exiting at regular intervals the
foundation has even been able to track a
group of passengers getting on the Corgi
transit system and getting off at a
later stop from this the foundation has
been able to estimate that the speed of
the system is 120 kmph excluding stops
to let passengers on and off along the
way which for the record is a pretty
leisurely Pace by train standards
naturally the SCP Foundation weren't
exactly thrilled to learn about an
anomalous transit system that worked to
spread further anomalies all over the
world in fact that's kind of a nightmare
scenario for them so they marshaled
their Global forces located each of the
openings along the torso of the Corgi
system and block them up at this point
the SCP Foundation were ready to give
themselves a pat on the back close up
shop for the night and go out for
afterwork drinks however there was one
thing that they'd all forgotten Hell
hath no fury like a society of Welsh Fay
who've just had their daily commute
ruined the Council of tywi with teg
their ruling body doesn't take kindly to
having their Public Services messed with
and the manner of their retaliation was
less like a group of disgruntled
anomalous civil servants and more like a
a kind of Fay mafia they would make the
foundation rule the day they messed with
Corgi with a series of retaliatory
strikes that group of Interest like
chaos Insurgency and the children of the
Scarlet King could only dream of it
began with the kidnapping of Project
Director Stevens who'd authorized the
containment project he vanished from his
apartment and was replaced with an adult
European mole which seems to be the Fay
equivalent of leaving a horse's head in
the bed as an offer you can't refuse to
send a message but it didn't stop up
there over the next 3 weeks 17 different
members of personnel specifically
construction workers who'd worked on the
project woke up to find the walls of
their houses had been entirely replaced
by Poison Ivy and death cap mushrooms
and after 2 months researcher Mills the
weird dog torturer we told you about
earlier woke up with a highly poisonous
nightshade berries in his mouth and
Hawthorn Stakes driven through his hands
and feet crucifixion style all
perpetrated by some very upset 3-in
transport workers at this point the
foundation put together who was behind
these attacks and decided to try to make
amends with the Fay whom they'd
understandably upset with their
treatment of Corgi a plan was drafted to
have all the SCP
29521 entrances unburied after this
undertaking was completed the Fay
retribution came to an end and most of
the damage was undone director Stevens
was returned unharmed the construction
workers got their walls back and while
researcher Mills didn't get better but I
think we can all agree that animal
cruelty isn't really a crime that we
should be forgiving lightly after all
this chaos had transpired and the SCP
Foundation had fully made amends
director Stevens had a note left on his
desk by a starling which then flew off
before it could be caught by the way can
we just take a second to appreciate that
the SCP Foundation has contained literal
demigods and interdimensional Horrors
but director Stevens was out foxed by a
bird wonderful those fa truly are built
different anyway a note on his desk
translated from Welsh R thank you for
your prompt response to commuter
complaints and wonderful customer
service as such we have granted all
members of your organization
complimentary Transportation on our
Corgi system please send a sparrow to
the Council of the city office nearest
you if you have further questions G
flock glove director of Transportation
the Council of the tyth teg and with
tremendous relief that the Slate had
finally been cleared the foundation
decided that they would accept the kind
offer extended to them by the council
and send one of their field agents to
take a look inside the Corgi system the
field agent in question was agent
Elizabeth Davies chosen for her Pleasant
social skill and Proficiency in Welsh
with the intention to take a ride in
mind and connected to an audio and video
feeds linked back to Central Command
agent Davies touched the site of Corgi
this caused her to shrink down to a
height of 3.2 CM much like all the other
commuters she stepped into the SCP 2952
entrance and found that on the inside it
looked not unlike a regular train though
some carriages seemed to be in disrepair
and everything was written in Welsh oh
and everything was made with wood and
plant matter too the chassis appeared to
be constructed from Birch and all the
seat cushions were made of flower petals
it was all very Whimsical honestly agent
Davies struck up conversations with some
of the other commuters one complained
about delays caused by the fact that
Corgi was suffering from kidney stones a
problem that the foundation is eager to
help the poor animal get over to keep
the transit system running smoothly she
also chatted with a sweet elderly lady
on the train who was getting people to
sign a petition to allow mice back onto
the Corgi transit system when agent
Davies Departed the system she patted
the dog and told him he was a good boy
before returning to normal size since
January 5th 2017 the Corgi system and
its passengers have become invisible to
everyone who wasn't officially under SCP
Foundation employ this has allowed it
for its reclassification as a safe
anomaly so there you have it Folks at
least at least one of our two very long
boys got everything sorted out we love
occasionally doing a happy ending here
at SCP explained remember to stay tuned
for our next episode about the time that
SCP 106 managed to get onto a school bus
what we did say
occasionally what's the largest animal
you can think of okay that's probably
too vague of a question your mind
probably went straight to the oceans
picturing deep sea leviathans like the
mighty blue whale let's go a little bit
closer shall we what about on land what
are the biggest animals that live up
here with us above the water elephants
maybe what about rhinos then again
hippos are up there too in the same kind
of ballpark all pretty huge what about
cows they can grow pretty big right
especially with all the crazy growth
hormones that meat manufacturers pump
into them these days well what if there
was something out there bigger than all
of those imagine it some huge Beast
roaming the Wilderness that easily
towered above above any creature you've
ever seen in your life this thing would
be massive striding across the world
towering above the meager height of a
human being now imagine that this thing
whatever it was wasn't just big but kept
getting bigger sure all of this might
sound like the premise for the next
Godzilla or Cloverfield movie but while
big Charlie might not be the king of the
monsters it certainly lives up to that
first part of its nickname of course the
SCP Foundation calls it SCP 4158 big
Charlie is just the playful nickname
that the owners gave it although none of
them are sure who was the first to call
the creature by that name standing on
four long legs at 3.4 M tall when the
foundation first discovered it SCP 4158
was about 1 and 35ths times as tall as
famous professional basketball player
Shaquille O'Neal but since then well
like we said big char is getting bigger
day by day the creature appears to be
tangentially related to the Bine family
of mammals essentially making it a
ginormous cow however SCP 4158 lacks the
facial structure and features that you
might expect to see on the faces at your
local Farm the creature has thin
translucent skin which is so fragile
that it often tears easily and anyone
observing SCP 4158 can often see the
bones and internal organs within gross
it possesses a large bulbous head with a
protrusion at the front almost like a
beak as well as that its huge eyes are
foggy a milky white color which seems to
suggest that SCP 4158 is at least
partially blind the large Cadillac
mammal is incredibly skinny almost to
the point where its bones stick out from
underneath its skin its legs are longer
than the rest of its colossal body and
seem barely able to support the animal's
weight on description alone you can't
help but but feels sorry for the poor
creature and its sorry state of living
normally big Charlie is mostly calm and
docile barely acknowledging the
foundation Personnel that come to
examine it feed it or clean its
containment cell held in a heavy
containment Zone SCP 4158 is fed through
a 5 m trough on the far East wall of its
cell surviving on a diet of raw beef hay
wood and Bricks not the typical grasson
eating habits you'd expect from normal
cows but according to the foundation
extensive testing on the creature its
diet doesn't seem to be what is causing
SCP 4158 to keep growing at the rate it
has been the mass of big Charlie is in
some sort of state of Perpetual increase
meaning its size and weight are always
growing and it is because of this
continuous growth that every week the
foundation is forced to Shear off great
swaths of excess meat from the creature
cleaving off its flesh and incinerating
the mass all while big Charlie is still
alive now before you start dialing
peta's hotline it's also worth
mentioning big Charlie can't feel pain
what's more testing has revealed that
the meat taken from SCP 4158 is USDA
utility grade beef the kind that would
normally come from older cattle utility
grade meat has no fat marbling so it
isn't as tender or as flavorsome as
other more premium grades but would
normally be used in canned and processed
food products and despite the foundation
destroying the excess that they cut off
of big Charlie as a precaution in theory
the meat is still good to eat and
possesses no anomalous properties then
again would you really want to eat a
burger made from SCP 4158 I didn't think
so if left unchecked and allowed to grow
for longer than a week SCP 4158 will
begin to form new features limbs organs
and sometimes even genitals will Sprout
from random places all over its body the
previous record for Big Charlie's most
substantial growth was when he increased
to 8 and 1/2 M tall that's over 3 fths
the height of the Hollywood sign and
over 1 and 1/2 times the average height
of a giraffe at this immense size
Charlie has developed seven legs four
stomachs three tongues and numerous
other extremities before the SCP
Foundation cut him back down to size and
we mean they literally cut him back down
so what exactly is this thing it's like
a giant cow but not actually a cow even
though its flesh is is identical to beef
and it's not a destructive rampaging
monster either showing no hostility
towards humans even when they are
shearing its excessive body mass away
could it be some kind of failed genetic
experiment an attempt to solve hunger by
engineering a creature that could not
only stay alive but keep growing after
having its meat cut away if that were
true it would make SCP 4158 a literal
Cash Cow for the meat industry well
we've got kind of a funny story about
that actually big Charlie was first
encountered by the foundation back in
December 2004 in kudon Indiana a number
of calls had been made to the area's
local animal control services with
reports of a large cow with mange
roaming the nearby Highway 17 two
officers belonging to the animal Control
Department were sent out to investigate
these reports and what they found was
SCP 4158 wandering aimlessly but unlike
any cow they had ever seen the officers
called local police where Foundation
plant caught wind of what they had found
and called in containment Specialists
the case was closed after the Animal
Control Officers were given amn sticks
and a cover story was put in place about
a cow with mange that was put down where
it had been found in reality the SCP
Foundation rounded up old big Charlie
and transported it to safety with Little
Resistance from the animal they were
able to trace the creature's origin back
to somewhere called butcher block a
nearby slaughterhouse the manager of the
establishment one Jeff fine and a single
employee named Barney Mossman were
brought in by the foundation for
questioning another employee Rory Gilson
was also retrieved from his home after
having called in sick to work that day
Barney Mossman the first of the Butcher
Block employees to be interviewed stated
that SCP 4158 had been called Big
Charlie since long before he had started
his job at the slaughterhouse according
to his testimony he knew nothing about
where the creature had actually come
from only that it was fed hay but would
also occasionally eat anything else it
could including other cows since joining
Butcher Block 4 years earlier Mossman
had been told not to ask questions or to
tell anyone else about SCP 4158 the
morning after the huge creature had
seemingly escaped Mr fine had apparently
angrily accused both Barney and Rory of
selling him out and giving big Charlie
away to the competitors of Butcher Block
even though they were the only
slaughterhouse in the area but Mossman
was convinced that neither of them were
capable of doing something like like
that Rory apparently treated big Charlie
like his own child and fine had an even
stranger relationship with the creature
Rory Gilson the other of fe's employees
was more helpful in shedding light on
SCP 4158 origin than Barney had been
Rory explained that he and Jeff fine had
bought a pregnant cow from an unknown
person 9 years earlier considering it to
be a steel a two for the price of one
bargain however one day without warning
the calf fell out of its mother it
wasn't born like any or AR cow however
according to gildon it had ripped
through the mother cow's chest and
looked disgusting while Rory and Jeff
had initially thought the calf to be
dead they discovered it had tried to get
back into the barn after they hauled it
outside their original intention had
been to sell the creature off for
scientific study or failing that to a
freak Show however after their attempts
to sell the calf failed Jeff and Rory
had decided the best course of action
would be to put the animal down they had
reasoned that releasing it into the wild
could could have negatively affected the
ecosystem so instead they took a bolt
pistol and pushed it between the
creature's eyes then fired but nothing
happened Rory tried again but ended up
breaking the gun instead they slit the
animal's throat but it barely bled even
butchering it on the Spot while it was
still alive did nothing finding Gilson
reduced the calf to little more than a
skeleton but it simply refused to Die
the pair of them packaged the meat they
had removed with the rest hoping no one
would notice or ask where it had come
from it was a few days later that Rory
realized SCP 4158 was capable of
regrowing whatever was cut off of it he
and his boss even tried some and
couldn't tell the difference they had
their hands on a cow that would eat
anything put in front of it and that
could produce infinite meat the
foundation probed Rory gildon further
for more information on the creature
learning that SCP 4158 was sterile and
incapable of reproducing the only one of
its kind Rory argued that the foundation
legally couldn't take big char Char away
that the creature was still private
property little did he realize he was
wrong but he just like Barney Mossman
also knew nothing about how the animal
had escaped in the first place finally
Jeff fine the owner of the Butcher Block
slaughterous was questioned by the
foundation he repeated Rory's earlier
story about the strange calf that had
been born and how it could regenerate
the flesh that was sheared off of it
fine remarked that he considered it to
be a blessing when asked about his
whereabouts on the night SCP 4158 had
escaped from Butcher's Block Jeff
admitted that he had been praying but
not to God to Big Charlie he had
apparently been doing this every night
since realizing what the creature could
do viewing the animal as a provider and
a savior I just felt something when I
was around him I could tell that he
wanted to make this sacrifice for us
ever since he tried to get into the barn
after we threw him out I knew he cared
for us fine told the foundation I would
open his pen take off my clothes so that
I was pure before him lay down and
receive His blessings and how would he
receive those Blessings by drinking the
animal's blood yeah Jeff fine was a real
eccentric like that one night when fine
had entered the pen to perform this
weird ritual big Charlie had escaped but
his owner was convinced that there must
have been a reason for this that the
animal had some sort of goal when the
foundation staff conducting find's
interview dismissed this idea The
Slaughterhouse owner became enraged how
dare you question big char
he knows what's best for all of us I'm
done here I don't need to keep answering
questions like this let me out I need to
see big Charlie I need to see if he's
safe the foundation believes that Jeff
Fine's practice of worshiping SCP 4158
was not due to any anomalous effect
caused by the creature itself none of
the foundation Personnel tested with
feeding studying and shearing meat off
of big Charlie have displayed any
similar behavior of Performing abnormal
religious rituals he really was just a
huge weirdo as for the Butcher Block
slaughterhouse fine and the rest of his
employees were given him KN sticks to
forget big Charlie had ever even existed
and the slaughterhouse was closed under
the false pretense of a health code
violation and its staff being arrested
for malpractice the one question that
remains unanswered however is the
identity of the individual that first
sold Jeff find the cow that gave birth
to SCP
4158 it just goes to show you though
sometimes you don't know where your food
is coming from if you lived in Indiana
in late 2004 who knows you might have
eaten some of big Charlie and not even
realized it Josie is a half cat no she
isn't half cat half something else and
she's not a humanoid with feline
features either she is literally half of
a cat actually to be more precise she is
the front half but in otherwise ordinary
black and gray tabby cat that is
ordinary apart from having no visible
back legs or hind quarters you might
think that make it hard for Josie to get
around but if you asked her on how only
being a half cat affects her on a daily
basis well she wouldn't be able to
answer you due to the simple fact that
cats generally can't speak but
nevertheless Josie will happily and
effortlessly walk around on her own two
legs moving as if she had a second pair
of hind legs in place behind behind her
her back half isn't invisible it's as if
it's not even there at all not showing
up on X-rays and yet it can give a
slight yield when touched being almost
tangible but not fully despite this
Josie suffers no adverse health problems
or any other complications despite
lacking one half of her body
occasionally she doesn't mind having her
semic corporeal Hine quarter stroked
although she will usually get a little
bit scratchy if people try that so how
does the SCP Foundation keep an anomaly
like Josie contained well it turns out
that they don't really need to she's
perfectly harmless and is actually
allowed to roam freely around the lower
levels of the facility she's kept at
casually as you like she slinks around
the corridors passing from one room to
the next of course if cats could talk
then Josie would probably tell you that
she has the run of the whole facility
the only real question left is what does
a half cat do when when she's left to
wander around a foundation facility
completely unsupervised easy she starts
looking for a ball of yarn Josie was
sure she'd seen one somewhere around
here one of the researchers had carried
it off for testing not too long ago her
small front paws padded against the
ground as Josie navigated her way to
where she last remembered seeing that
coveted ball of yarn being taken she
passed a group of researchers one of
them kneeling down to give her a
friendly scratch behind the ears just as
she closed her eyes and purred at the
greeting a sound coming from down the
hall startled her it was a low
distressed sobbing having never been
taught that old saying about curiosity
and cats Josie slunk past the
researcher's legs towards the source of
the noise the room that the crying was
coming from had no windows no way for
her to get in luckily Josie despite only
having half a body had enough
determination and resourcefulness for
two whole cats around the corner she
knew there was an open air vent and sure
enough she leaped gracefully up to it
with ease the cold metal tunnel was just
big enough to accommodate her little
furry self as she crawled through the
echoing sound of sobs guiding her as she
reached the great looking out into the
windowless room Josie spotted a tall
thin creature sitting with its back to
her its arms would have been long enough
to reach the ground if it had stood at
its full height but for now they were
wrapped tightly around its legs as the
creature rocked back and forth its loud
whales showed that it was clearly in a
great deal of distress although Josie
wouldn't be able to understand why
having someone look at its face would
make this slender creature so upset
nearby there was a giant metal cube with
a hole ripped in it and while the rest
of the room was empty there seemed to be
several large red smears on the ground
how strange she cocked her head to one
side and meowed tapping one paw against
the air vent grate it seemed pretty
loose with a few good pushes the screws
came fre
and the adorable half cat hopped down
into the room as she got closer to the
creature she noticed it had a black bag
covering its face little did Josie know
an hour earlier a junior researcher had
made the terrible mistake of putting on
a pair of X-ray glasses he ordered from
the back of a comic book as it turns out
these were the only ones to ever
actually work he saw right through 96's
containment Cube and all hell had broken
loose but Josie didn't mind she she
decided to endear herself to the strange
shy creature by rubbing up against its
long leg returning the same affection
that it had so rarely been given it bent
down and gently scooped Josie up in its
spinley arms the pair of them sat in the
corner together Josie getting herself
comfortable on the tall creature's lap
purring as long fingers ran over her
Tabby fur the creature being so careful
not to harm the half cat treated her
like she was as delicate as glass it had
briefly stopped crying thanks to its
visitor and as as much as she noticed
the sounds of sobbing had ceased Josie
would never understand the difference
she had made to scp096 his day
unfortunately it wasn't long before
their encounter was cut short a legion
of guards in scramble goggles burst into
the room to retake control of the
situation the last thing they expected
to see was 096 sitting calmly with Josie
on its lap and a bag covering its face
but the sudden entrance of a security
team startled the poor half cat within a
second she had bolted out of the the
room shooting under the legs of the
guards and back out into the facility
now that she was back outside Josie
recalled her earlier hunt for a ball of
yarn to play with she still wasn't sure
where it had gotten to maybe someone had
moved it pacing over to the elevator she
stared up at the heavy steel doors the
numbers above were gradually ticking
down denoting Which floor the elevator
had currently stopped at of course Josie
couldn't read so instead she sat and
meowed loudly at the elevator maybe if
she made enough noise the doors would
eventually open eventually after a few
short minutes of waiting and growling
the doors slid apart another gaggle of
researchers passed her by and Josie
plotted into the elevator spotting a
familiar face one of the researchers a
Doctor by the name of Sophie Cartwright
was still inside and smiled down at the
half-cat Explorer Dr cartwrite had come
across Josie a few times enough for the
Intrepid little tabby to consider them
friends where to Josie Dr cartright
asked her hand hovering over the
elevator's buttons as if in reply Josie
looked up and meowed humans always
seemed to smile if she meowed after
they'd said something to her Sophie
chuckled and pushed the door close
button hold the elevator another much
grelier voice called a hand or rather a
paw reached out and caught the doors
before they could slide closed it was
another of the foundation's doctors one
with both a considerable reputation and
a very distinguishing look to say the
least Dr Kane paos Crow stepped inside
the elevator and pushed one of the
buttons Sophie had to force herself to
keep her head down but couldn't help
herself from stealing the occasional
glance up at Dr Crow she heard the
rumors about A peculiar anomalous event
changing his appearance but had never
seen him up close before Josie on the
other hand couldn't take her eyes off
Crow staring up at him froze to the spot
and letting out a low cautious wine if
her tail was visible Sophie would have
seen it swaying from side to side as The
Brave Little half-cat kept her defensive
ground standing between her friend Dr
cartright and her mortal enemy you see
Dr Crow was a dog or at least a man who
had been turned into something very much
like a dog still capable of speech but
with a distinctively canine body Crow
kept to himself the entire ride down
although Sophie could feel the tension
between the dog body doctor and her
little half-cat friend out of the corner
of his eye Dr Crow spotted Josie trying
his best to ignore her he let out a low
discomforted growl the kind of dog makes
when they're on edge to his credit he
couldn't really help it the man had been
turned into a canine after all but it
took all his stoicism to suppress a bark
and to stop himself from chasing Josie
around the cramped elevator arriving at
her floor Sophie stepped down followed
by little Josie who Moved as far away
from Crow as quickly as she could the
doors closed once more and sent him
further down into the depths of the
facility as she turned to look Sophie
noticed Josie had craned her head up to
check on her a were you protecting me
Josie she asked with a smile bending
down to thank the half cat with a
scratch behind the ears before she could
stay for too long Josie and her human
companion parted each heading down
separate winding corridors there was a
funny smell hanging in the air like
something gradually melting and bubbling
only to reform and melt again filling
the half cat's pink nose with a strange
burning scent as she passed a holding
cell something broke josy's
concentration yet again again the noise
of a hand tapping at glass she turned
and instantly meowed a greeting to the
second familiar face of the day albeit a
more beaked face kneeling down on the
other side of the glass the black robed
plague doctor waved politely at the Dual
pod passer by sitting in front of the
glass hoping to be let in Josie gave
another meow I'm quite well the doctor
mused and how are you my dear he asked
politely Josie got up on her back legs
or rather that's what it would have
looked like if she had hind quarters
instead it looked like she was almost
floating in place from halfway down
stretching her front paws up reaching
towards the birdlike face as the mask
Doctor playfully tapped his fingers
against the glass to amuse his feline
friend no I cannot let you in I'm afraid
he sighed sounding a touch more
melancholic not that a half cat can
understand the difference in someone's
Cadence not all of us here are gifted
the freedom you enjoy my furry friend
freedom is not something this or
organization would ever understand no
matter how much they claim to know us
the fact of the matter is they never
really listened from the other side of
the glass Josie blinked and cocked her
head to one side confused she'd barely
heard a word he said oh but listen to me
Goan the plague doctor chuckled wrapping
his fingers in front of the half cat
again I suppose you'll be looking for
that ball of yarn they took for testing
I saw them carrying the box it was in
that way he pointed and josy's little
green cat eyes followed the the
direction of his finger barely able to
comprehend what had been said to her she
simply meowed up in thanks and plotted
the way she'd been directed F Well
little Josie as CP 049 said quietly from
inside its cell watching the half cat
until she had disappeared from view as
she continued through the lower levels
of the facility Josie slipped through
doors seconds before they closed leapt
up onto tables and dashed between legs
that strange smell was back having
caught her attention and distracted her
from her Quest again tracking it to its
source Josie suddenly felt uneasy she
entered a room with a huge vat of acid
the source of the burning scent she'd
picked up on though it was what was
inside the vet trapped in a loop of
regenerating itself only to be melted
over and over again by the acid that got
her feeling defensive the vast reptilian
monstrosity sensed a small life form
outside its tank and opened one yellow
eye squinting through the Searing
burning acid had the tiny little
creatures staring up at it the reptile
snarled screwing its now healed eyes
shut and swiping what was left of its
limbs at the glass rearing back Josie
gave the monster her fiercest hiss
bearing her fangs at it the Beast
usually abhor other beings finding all
other forms of life unnatural
unforgivable and so detestable that it
would normally stop at nothing to
eradicate them but today a tiny tabby
cat with her entire back half missing
was standing up to the crocodilian
Nightmare and it barely had enough will
to retaliate maybe it was just too
lethargic too tired to try anything
today perhaps it didn't think she was
worth the effort or figured it would see
to her along with the researchers and
guards next time it broke free from
containment and went on yet another
Killing Spree but in Josie's mind this
facility was her home and The Brave
Little half-cat had scared SCP 682 into
staying put as she trotted away again
she knew that the Monstrous reptile
would have to think twice before messing
with her back on track at last Josie
rounded the corner and arrived in a
familiar looking Corridor she was
certain this was where she'd seen a
researcher carrying the Box containing
the string that she coveted sure enough
she could see into the room where the
Box had been left noticing a group of
researchers and a human in an orange
jumpsuit were gathered around it a few
were making notes on their clipboards at
a safe distance while the one in Orange
Ste closer to the Box Josie watched as a
single bee flew out of the box her
feeline eyes followed it ready to pounce
if it came close enough the man wearing
the jumpsuit was waving his arms trying
to swat the insect away a moment later
he grabbed his arm in pain the bee had
gotten agitated stinging him and flying
away somehow surviving as she waited
Josie's patience was rewarded the
researchers and the man wearing orange
bustled their way out of the room
offering her the chance she needed to
zip between them and get one step closer
to her prize the room was entirely empty
save for the the box in the center
sitting precariously at top a table
wiggling herself as she readied her
invisible and intangible back legs Joy
shot up just missing the table's Edge
she clawed and scratched at the surface
trying to pull herself up but her lack
of hind quarters made it impossible to
climb the rest of the way dropping back
to the floor she looked up at the table
and gave it a loud indignant meow
changing tactics she started to hop up
on one of the table legs digging her
claws into the woodwork to hoist herself
up bit by bit sure enough her new
strategy worked a treat and Josie was
presented with what she had been
searching for one final hurdle was left
however the box was closed now the
struggles of only being a half cat are
one thing but not having opposable
thumbs is a difficulty that has plagued
all cats since the dawn of time but not
being able to grab or hold things with
the ease of a human there's one thing
that cats are great at and that's
pushing things over nudging the box to
the table's edge with a gentle Boop of
her nose Josie eventually tipped the
whole thing off causing it to land on
its side on the floor the lid falling
open triumphantly she jump back down to
claim her prize expecting to find the
ball of yarn and spend the next few
hours playing with it but something was
wrong the yarn had changed and now it
was looking at her the ball had started
as yarn and ribbon the perfect play
thing for any half cat or full cat for
that matter but the foundation had been
running their usual invasive tests on it
and since cutting a portion of the
string off it had transformed it was now
a ball of meat functioning blinking eyes
staring out of a mass of overlapping
sinine and blood red matter the multiple
eyes looked up at the half cat that had
knocked it to the floor and asked a
single question in a deep voice
emanating from somewhere within its
lipless form are you Eric completely
unfazed by this Josie whacked the ball
with her paw and watched as it rolled
halfway across the room tentacle
segments of its body gradually pulled
the Amorphis mask back to where it
started and then asked once again are
you Eric once again Josie slapped the
ball and watched it rolled away from her
both completely unaware of who Eric was
and a little perturbed that someone had
replaced the ball of yarn with such an
inadequate toy turning her back on SCP
066 Josie the half cat searched for a
way out of the room and went back to
prowling around the facility for
something to entertain herself she
noticed that she was starting to get
hungry maybe if she got lucky one of the
researchers would sneak her a piece of
cheese who doesn't love their pets right
whether it's a dog a cat a goldfish or a
hamster any pet owner will tell you that
their furry friend is so much more than
just an animal that they adopted to many
pets become permanent additions to the
family well they might not look like a
human being or even have the ability to
speak the way we do a lot of owners view
their pets as people in their own right
of course a person can't be a pet at
least a human person can't right well
not unless you happen to be a part of
SCP
1897 otherwise known as the human
domestication Society if you've ever
been brave enough to travel alone to the
rural parts of Southwestern States like
Arizona New Mexico Texas Oklahoma Utah
or Nevada then it's likely you would
have been an ideal victim for SCP
1897 this designation doesn't refer to
one single creature or entity but rather
a group of similar beings witness
testimonies and photographs of SCP 1897
depict them as humanoid creatures
standing approximately 5 m in height
these beings have displayed a speed and
strength far beyond that of any human
they are capable of traveling roughly
200 m in only 9 seconds and lifting
weights of up to 500 kilos with a single
hand these entities are not Immortal and
can be harmed by by conventional means
but that doesn't mean it's an easy task
any SCP 1897 instance that is killed or
incapacitated immediately vanishes
resulting in them dropping anything that
they may have been carrying at the time
and surprisingly these are not mindless
monsters and actually appear to be
capable of communication furthermore
they do not seem to speak a unique or
distinct language but instead
communicate in standard American English
with ACC and vernacular appropriate to
the regions they appear in however they
will actively refuse to reply to any
human that attempts to engage them in
conversation now these creatures don't
spend every waking hour of the day
roaming around the states of Texas
Oklahoma and all the others we listed if
they did it's likely a lot more
civilians would have spotted them by now
and would probably live their lives in
fear of these gigantic 5 m tall
humanoids but instances of SCP 1897 will
only manifest if certain specific
criteria are met and these are as
follows to encounter SCP
1897 a person must be alone or part of a
group of no more than two if more than
one person is with them then no
manifestation will occur there is one
exception to the rule if a child under
the age of 12 is present secondly
neither the person nor anyone with them
can be carrying any kind of weapon that
means no knives no guns not even pepper
spray third and finally they must be at
least 25 M from a major population
Center and what happens when all of
these conditions are met and one of
these creatures appears anyone
witnessing their arrival will notice the
creatures materializing appearing to
emerge from some form of unseen vehicle
when they manifest the SCP 1897 entities
are almost always carrying long poles
with large Nets at the end as well as
steel cages and are often seen wearing
dark green uniforms in most cases they
will attempt to capture any nearby
person in a way that causes them the
least possible harm should an SCP 1897
creature successfully apprehend a person
and place them in a cage both them and
their captive will vanish in a similar
manner to the way the creature appeared
all attempts to track SCP 1897 or one of
its abductive victims have failed there
is no way to know where they are taken
but as far as what happens to them that
we do have a little more insight to
sometimes although it is a highly rare
occurrence the captured human victims
May reappear around a month after their
capture while never in the same location
as where they disappeared from they will
always be accompanied by an SCP 1897
instance and will stay close by the
creatures side at this point the
abductee is barely human anymore they
are considered an instance of what is
known as SCP 1897 death -1 what
signifies this sudden and drastic
transformation for one these victims are
always found to have been forcibly
castrated or sterilized essentially no
longer able to reproduce the way humans
naturally do for another these instances
of SCP 18971 universally display a
decreased level of cognitive and mental
function what we mean is that their
brains do not function the way they
should anymore instead these abductees
exhibit the same level of intell Ence
and capability as the average canis
lupus familiaris otherwise known as the
common domestic dog should someone
attempt to rescue a person that has
become an instance of SCP
18971 or display hostility towards the
SCP 1897 creature that accompanies them
they will be met with outward
animalistic aggression from the victim
it has been discovered by the SCP
Foundation that these behaviors can be
treated with amnestics unfortunately
though the process of an abducted person
becoming an SCP
18971 instance seems to be the result of
an invasive medical procedure known as a
lumbotomy this typically involves
removing or disabling certain parts of
the human brain meaning that what has
been done to these victims is permanent
and cannot be reversed so who is doing
all of this why are these creatures
collecting innocent human beings only to
reduce them to little more than animals
the answers lie in something currently
referred to as scp1
18972 not another creature or entity not
an anomalous artifact or location with
strange properties but a website found
at the address
www.hd society. goov according to the
information on this site it belongs to a
group calling themselves the human
domestication Society the website
features Pages such as adoption training
breeding programs volunteering and more
the fact that this is the kind of
website you might expect to be about
dogs or cats but instead focuses on the
domestication of humans is certainly
enough to turn the stomach as we said at
the start of the video surely a human
being can't be somebody's pet right
wrong at least as far as the human
domestication Society goes their website
contains everything and anything one of
these SCP 1897 creatures could ever hope
to learn about owning a human as a pet
has your Human been miss behaving need
to train them to use the toilet these
Pages have all the information you need
to help your human become the most
well-trained human on your block boast
the training page of
www.hd society. goov the remainder of
the page contains links to various
articles such as obedience training
which claims an owner of a human can
show them who boss without the need for
physical violence also featured are
mentions of how to toilet train or play
fetch with a human how to introduce a
human to to others due to them naturally
not getting along perhaps most chilling
of all is one article titled
understanding what your human wants that
warrants human beings shouldn't talk and
another dealing with Strays offers tips
for anyone wanting to learn to capture
their own pets themselves it doesn't
seem like too much of a leap to think
that the SCP 1897 creatures have
followed a lot of the advice from this
particular article arguably worst of all
is an image featured on the website s of
a tall menacing SCP 1897 entity
brandishing a picana electrica this
device for any unfamiliar with the term
is a form of high voltage electrical
cattle prod normally used for the
purposes of torture in the photograph in
question the creature is wielding one of
these while standing sternly over a
helpless captive human male now an
instance of SCP
18971 with tears in his eyes further
Pages found on www W.D society. goov
recommends solutions to certain human
behaviors for example like one might
expect to find on other Pet Care
websites some of the human domestication
society's articles pertain to dealing
with aggression grooming house training
and even toilet training then there's
the adoption page which states we offer
a large variety of humans for adoption
every single day while we cannot
guarantee a human UC listed on our
website will be available when you reach
the shelter our inventory is updated
every half hour we cannot answer any
questions about specific humans pictured
on our website over the phone or email
it is still unclear whether or not the
SCP 1897 creatures that have been known
to appear in the southwestern United
States are sent out to gather humans and
Mass to offer for adoption or whether
these creatures are individuals trying
to obtain human pets on their own of
course the worst conceivable answer is
both the site is horrifying in ly
comprehensive with links to an actual
human ownership convention with panels
on breeding and preventing illegal human
poaching and skinning it's safe to say
if that you were ever unlucky enough to
read this website it would Haunt You for
Life naturally the SCP Foundation has
made several attempts to contact the
owners of this website they tried in
vain to communicate through the official
channels about SCP 18971 adoption as a
way of peacefully negotiating that the
human domestication Society website be
shut down as well as its practices of
capturing lumbotomy breeding and
adopting humans however these
communication attempts were met with
silence that is until a message was
received by the foundation at site 06
addressed to a member of personel that
does not exist no data pertaining to the
physical location of the cender could be
derived from the email but it was traced
to the same IP address as the human
domestication society's website the
email read as follows
we will not listen to your lies any
longer it was you who came after us
first you who tore holes in our world
and tried to annihilate us you who took
our olive branch of peace and fashioned
it into a spear you who nearly drove us
to Extinction and now that we have the
advantage you attempt to patronize us
with your crocodile tears we will not be
deceived again but unlike you we are not
monsters we have much anger towards your
kind but we are willing to forgive but
first you must be willing to change
slavery and genocide are immoral and not
even you deserve such a fate it is our
belief then that this alternative is a
fair compromise between guaranteeing our
safety and allowing your kind to live
this is our Mercy to you look at the
humans who have gone through our program
see how much happier they are your
correspondence tells us that you have
seen them see how much they love us why
why then do you continue to be defiant
someday you will thank us please try to
understand that this is for your own
good for now there is little that the
SCP Foundation can do to prevent the
human domestication Society from
abducting human beings to sell us pets
to other SCP 1897 creatures civilian
access to the HD society. goov website
has been restricted so we recommend you
stop typing into the search bar of your
browser to go take a peak yes we mean
you seriously stop that as for the
entities that have appeared in the rural
areas of the southwestern States all the
foundation can do is position its agents
nearby in the hopes that they can detain
and neutralize the SCP 1897s as they
appear with lethal Force if necessary at
present the only procedure for any human
pets that are successfully recaptured is
to have them moved safely to containment
until a way of rehabilitating them is
found so far there hasn't been any luck
on that front there's an app for that
wait hold on I'm Steve
Jobs come on don't stop it it was a
phrase so ubiquitous in the early days
of the smartphone craze that it's hard
to believe Apple actually has
trademarked it was a testament to a
simple and immutable truth about the
world these new touchscreen phones were
creating no matter how strange and
obscure the need there would be an app
to fulfill it perhaps you remember iBeer
the app that allowed you to pretend you
were drinking a tall glass of beer for
some reason there was car M an app that
reminded you where you parked your car
in a pirate voice and who could forget I
am bred a surreal game about controlling
a sentient slice of bread on a quest to
become toast but there's one app out
there somewhere on the market that you
probably didn't download and if you did
well you have our sincerest apologies
because even seeing this video pop out
onto your feed probably sent a chill
down your spine well if that chill ever
even left take it from one gentleman
whose life took a very strange turn
after downloading a certain app that the
SCP Foundation calls SCP
1471 because the sentiment there's an
app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal Terror Joe Lis an
insurance salesman from Milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of a name
Babble sensing the whole time that she
really wasn't that interested his date
excused himself to take a quick phone
call outside sadly for Joe she never
returned leaving him to pick up the
check of all the many words you could
use to describe Poor Joe Lis the most
pertinent would be lonely ever since
Carol his wife of 10 years had passed
away in a freak accident he'd been
trying to find some kind of way to fill
the void they'd been high school
sweethearts intent on spending the rest
of their lives with one another as fate
would have it only Carol would get that
tainted luxury Joe would be forced to
endure life after the joy of living had
run its course he only hoped he might be
lucky enough to find love again however
Joe was on the wrong side of 40 and as
so many others his age were already
hitched he could feel his options going
out one by one would he be destined to
live out the rest of his days alone Joe
did didn't feel like spending the back
half of his life catching reruns of
Seinfeld and tending to his fish he
needed to get out there and thankfully
like the rest of us he lived in the
internet age he had more apps websites
online services and hot Russian singles
in his area than he knew what to do with
so surely one would have the right
person for him he tried them all Tinder
hinge match.com Plenty of Fish e-harmony
Bumble zus Okay Cupid FriendFinder
deeply lonely singles with low
expectations. comom and so much more
however all it seemed to achieve was
setting him up for more disappointment
none of the dates he'd managed to get
ever resulted in anything getting
serious heck it was a minor miracle if
he even managed to get any of them on a
second date was this it was this his
life now had he only ever gotten one
shot at love and the grasping claws of
Fate yanked it away from him without a
second thought would life continue on
the hamster wheel of loneliness sleeping
getting up eating working and sleeping
again every day getting somehow both
faster and slower as life trudged on to
a disappointing yet inevitable
conclusion what a terrible fate to find
yourself trapped in whenever Joe started
feeling modlin like this he knew it was
time to get proactive again maybe the
right woman was out there there were
billions of them after all surely at
least one of them would be the perfect
person for him he just needed the
perfect app he'd burned through all of
the most reputable apps already and was
now perusing some of the slightly or
seedier options most of which were
likely data mining fronts from the
Vulcans however as generic app after
generic app passed something different
caught his eye the icon was a smiling
cartoon dog and its name was Malo
version
1.0.0 this gave him a little chuckle at
the very least it was very different
branding from the rest the dating apps
he'd seen maybe it just been sorted into
the wrong section of the App Store he
decided he'd check it out and take a
look at the apps description the
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of mow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember the
more you participate the more Malo will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy well
it certainly provoked Joe's curiosity at
the very least he did want to banish his
feelings of loneliness and seeing as the
app was free and apparently had no ads
he'd surely be foolish to not at least
give it a whirl what's the worst that
could happen he began the installation
and only then noticed that the app had
no listed developer it took up 9.8 MB of
memory which he wasn't Tech heavy enough
to see any issues with more than
anything Joe was just enticed by the
prospect of finally having another
chance at companionship with Malo after
all it is the next social substitute
whatever that means however Joe's
excitement was quickly quashed when he
hit the home screen button and noticed
that the icon for the app never actually
materialized
strange he checked the App Store portal
again and saw that according to them the
app had completely downloaded what gives
was it a glitch or was Malo actually
just malware either way he was
disheartened by the fact that this
immaterial app certainly wouldn't be
getting him any companionship or so he
thought anyway Joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more Seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to cry himself to sleep again
Malo was already becoming a distant
memory just like all the deceptive
sources of home but one strange thing
happened that disrupted Joe's finally
tuned evening routine he received a text
message this was incredibly strange
because nobody ever seemed to text him
the last text he got was from Carol just
before her accident so it was almost
surreal to hear that alert sound now
after everything that happened he
checked and saw that the text was an
image attachment sent from an unknown
number perplexed yet curious he decided
to open it his curiosity soon gave way
to a kind of melancholy Nostalgia when
he saw that the photo was of his and
Carol's favorite Cafe in town they'd
spent many a morning there back when she
was alive treating themselves to a nice
cup of coffee and perhaps a Quant just
seeing it again caused an involuntary
smile to spread across his face it never
even occurred to him as it probably
would have to others that this could be
seen as a little creepy he hadn't
frequented the bakery since Carol died
how would anyone even know that this
place held any significance for him was
it a stalker a ghost or just a spooky
coincidence none of these thoughts even
crossed Joe's mind he was just grateful
for the surprising reminder of the
happiness he'd once had for the next
couple hours things seemed lighter he
went about his ear evening checking the
photo every so often and smiling until
eventually he found himself in bed still
looking into the glow of his phone it
was such a beautiful little cafe then he
froze he noticed something in the
picture it'd been there the whole time
but only now he was seeing rather than
just looking it was in the corner
staring through the glass of the cafe
store so faint he almost wanted to
dismiss it as a trick of the light it
was a face well not a face more like a
skull not a human not anywhere near
human long slender and canine with
protruding fangs and vacant white eyes
the Pure White of the skull was buried
in a nest of thick black hair it looked
like it was crouching behind the door
looking out and grinning whatever the
hell it was just seeing it change the
entire tone of the picture it was no
longer a simple reminder of bygone Joy
now all that was radiating out of of
that image was a palpable sense of dread
was someone playing some kind of awful
prank on him just then he was jogged
from his contemplation by another alert
a new message from the same number as
before with great hesitation he hovered
his thumb over the push notification and
clicked that's when everything got a lot
worse it was a photo of a bus stop not
just any bus stop of course it was stop
c16 the one that Joe always took to get
to work it looked like it was taken
relatively early in the morning but
nobody was there well not quite nobody
there was that figure again it stood at
full height behind the partially frosted
glass that makes up the back of the bus
stop the same large black humanoid shape
with a white grinning dog skull where
the face should be something about it
terrified him on such a primal level
like the way our lizard brain reacts to
some ancient apex predator and whatever
this thing was it clearly knew something
about him how else could it stage all
these photos Joe got out of bed and
looked out of the window down onto his
dark Front Street empty thankfully but
after this surprised nightmare he wasn't
going to take any chances he grabbed a
kitchen knife from downstairs and placed
it on his bedside cabinet right next to
his phone with 911 on speed dial Joe Lis
a 43-year-old man slept with the lights
on that night for the first time in over
30 years years sadly for him the
nightmare was just beginning the next
morning Joe woke up unharmed but he
wasn't pleased to see that he'd gotten
several more texts in his sleep there
was one taken outside of the local
insurance company office where he worked
the strange creature with the skull for
a face was looming around the corner
peering at the camera with its lipless
grin like it was mocking him another
photo was taken at the local supermarket
where Joe did most of his grocery
shopping the frame was centralized on on
the seral aisle bordered on both sides
by walls of garish mascots endlessly
repeated down at the far end of the
aisle was a looming dark figure with
that cold canine skull where a human
face should be there were a few more but
worst of all was the last one it was
taken at the cemetery in the foreground
a headstone reading Carol Lis beloved
wife and daughter Joe was horrified to
see that skull-faced Beast was rising up
behind his wife's grave long clawed
fingers curling around the top of the
headstone that was the moment that Joe
decided to go to the police about all of
this before things got even more out of
hand he called an Uber to get down to
the station he certainly didn't feel
like he was going anywhere near his
regular bus stop after last night he
showed the photos he'd been sent so far
to an officer posted at the station and
they agreed that there was certainly
something strange about it while the
behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment it hadn't yet delved into
into criminal territory so he would
sadly be on his own until then the best
they could do was stay in touch and kept
a breast of any new developments the
only Sage advice they could give him was
not to delete the photos as they could
always be used as evidence in cord later
if things escalated this was literally
the last result that Joe wanted out of
this considering how bizarre and
threatening things were getting already
he really didn't want to find out what
escalation looked like in this case but
what else could he do but carry on just
trying to exercise as much caution as he
could in these strange new circumstances
he went to work and tried his best to
stay productive despite the fact that
every 3 or so hours a new photo would
arrive places that he liked to sit in
the local parks stores he'd frequent
restaurants he liked to eat at the
nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them just mugging for
the camera on one hand every time he
looked at one of the photos Joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly Look Away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the evening Joe may have not
been a genius but he was no fool either
he'd seen too many of those CD true
crime documentaries about kidnapping to
take his normal route home he took a
real detour frequently checking over his
shoulder the entire time much to his
relief he didn't see anything out of
place good when he got home he locked
every door and bolted every window
nothing would be getting the jump on him
tonight that's when the next picture
came in a photograph of Joe's empty
office cubicle with the Bony face of the
creature looming over the divider with a
grin he could feel his heart pounding
away in his chest just looking at it how
did this thing get around like this how
was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire goddamn life suddenly he felt
a smile spreading across Lo his face
this freak had just messed up big time
before all these creepy photos had been
taken in public places but the one taken
in his office oh this crossed the line
into trespassing the police would have
to do something about it now it had
given him an ace up his sleeve that
confidence faded a few hours later when
he received another photo this time it
was the skullface monster just standing
on the sidewalk the sidewalk that Joe
remembered walking on his covert alter
ative route he could feel himself break
into a cold sweat it seemed whoever this
was he really did hold no secrets from
them now more than ever Joe didn't feel
safe in his own home so you can only
imagine how he felt when a few hours
later he received a photo of the
skull-faced stalker standing right
outside his own front door staring into
the camera it sent him rushing to the
window again to check outside but of
course nobody was there the next day
when he called the police and updated
them on the situation they told him that
they were doing all they could the best
thing he could possibly do was to remain
calm but Vigilant he needed to keep an
eye on the photos being sent to him so
he could notify them if ever he was in
any immediate danger this put poor Joe's
paranoia at a fever pitch even when he
went to work surrounded by his
co-workers by Witnesses he could
scarcely tear his eyes away from his
phone he was a slave to the photo
forever waiting for the next one only to
experience crushing regret when the
photo actually arrived it looked like it
was taken moments before it was sent to
him Joe saw himself looking at his own
phone in his office cubicle with that
huge skull-faced figure looming behind
him he screamed out loud upon seeing it
and turned to see if anything was behind
him but of course there was nothing
there the police inspected the office
talked to potential Witnesses and
analyzed the photo it showed no signs of
any photographic manipulation but there
were also no witnesses around the office
who claimed to see anything strange that
day there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out Joe
lilis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and
everpresent feeling that he was in great
danger he didn't come into work the next
day he'd received more photos like that
in the night of himself taken in real
time with that skullface freak looming
he didn't want to leave the house he
didn't want to go anywhere anymore he
just didn't feel safe out there how
could he with all this madness unfolding
there was a time where he could have
said something like at least it only
seems confined to my phone he might have
even suspected that it had something to
do with that strange mow app he
downloaded a few days prior that hadn't
seemed to do anything but this situation
had evolved since then he wasn't just
seeing the creature in photos anymore it
was here he kept seeing quick flashes of
it on the other side of Windows in
Reflections in the corner of his eyes
always darting away if ever he turned
towards it it was everywhere and nowhere
it was here just for him he just knew
the police couldn't help nobody could
help Joe just sat in the corner of his
bedroom clutching his kitchen knife
afraid to close his eyes it could be
anywhere it could be anywhere it could
be anywhere we know one thing for sure
Joe Lis never felt truly alone ever
again he always had his new friend
waiting just out of sight and if ever
you're feeling Lonesome and decide to
download Malo version 1.0.0 yourself
then you'll never feel lonely again
either Ranger halter felt the bark of
the tree trunk slamming into his back
practically knocking all the air out of
his lungs as he tried desperately to
slow his frantic breathing the sound of
his own panting filled him with a sudden
horrifying thought if he could hear his
own ragged breaths then it could hear
them too he clamped a hand over his
mouth quenching his Jaws shut so tightly
that he thought his teeth might Splinter
as he pushed them together his free hand
gried the tranquilizer gun shuttering as
the snap of a twig rang out somewhere
behind him it had caught up to him
already he could bolt make a quick dash
for a cover behind another tree but it
was close enough now that it would see
him and if it did it would come rushing
after him with a speed that even a
season park ranger couldn't match as
much as he tried to force himself to
stay still the Petrified curiosity got
the better of him halter peaked out from
behind the tree and immediately wished
he hadn't it had all started out as what
sounded like an everyday occurrence high
at top his watchtower in the Glacier
National Park Ranger halter had been
enjoying the view of Montana's Rocky
Mountains a cup of coffee from his
thermos in his hand then the familiar
squawk of His Radio had cut short his
appreciation of the Serene scenery hter
side tossing the remaining contents of
the cup over the tower's railing
wondering what kind of day he was in for
as he went to answer the radio most of
the time things in Glacier Park were as
peaceful as they looked but the park
ranger knew that St being vigilant could
make all the difference when it came to
finding a missing hiker in time or the
difference between deterring a group of
campers away from a family of bears and
having a hell of a mess to clean up he
pushed down on the button for the
microphone connected to the bulky radio
that took up practically an entire desk
halter thank God came the relieved voice
from the other side we've been trying to
reach everyone put them on alert we've
got trouble reports of a coyote gone
feral attacking folks I'm on it hter
replied grabbing his gear from the
cramped Watchtower as he continued to
speak into the mic where did the report
come in from not far from your station
I'd say about a click West from your
position stowing his tranquilizer gun
Ranger holder descended the ladder from
his Watchtower down to ground level as a
park ranger holder valued the
environment he worked in and as a fan of
the SCP Universe we know how much you
value intricate World building or in
some cases World destroying but either
way we couldn't be happier to introduce
you to the sponsor of today's video
World Anvil World Anvil is a
comprehensive set of world building
tools that not only help you craft and
organize your unique setting but also
present it in a captivating manner from
wiklike articles and interactive maps to
a full-fledged RPG campaign manager and
novel writing software World Anvil has
everything a World creator could dream
of world Anvil equips you with over 25
templates prompting you to dive deeper
into your Creations enrich your content
by embedding Maps images sound effects
and even little secrets for that
immersive touch with their Innovative
design you can easily visualize your
world through Maps Chronicle its history
with timelines and fine-tune events with
intricate details your crafted world can
be beautifully showcased on a unique
homepage inviting others to dive into
your vision got a sudden idea while
working on another no problem World
envil lets you swiftly create new
articles or link existing ones ensuring
you never lose track of your inspiration
but my personal favorite feature is
their interactive maps Beyond just
creating and uploading your own designs
you can directly link your creations
allowing for a dynamic and engaging
experience and if you're collaborating
invite your team to refine write and
even let your fans chip in I'm currently
working on my own interactive map of
site 17 and maybe I'll even let you see
it when I'm done but don't wait for me
dive into World Anvil yourself and
elevate your world building game and
here's a treat use our Link in the
description to go to worldanvil tocom
and use the code SCP to grab a whopping
51% off any yearly subscription explore
create and share with World anvil the
sun was already starting to dip out of
sight behind the trees pretty soon it'd
be pitch black save for the beam of his
flashlight he had to move fast coyotes
were only known to attack humans on rare
occasions usually they kept away at
least enough to make them a minimal risk
but waiting for him just west of the
Watchtower wasn't a coyote at least not
at first watching it from behind the
tree moments later Ranger Halter's
stomach turned at the sight of the
creature it walked by Pally like a human
but the shape was all wrong its legs
looked broken but that hadn't stopped it
from catching up instead of bending at
the knee they were z-shaped pointing
back behind the creature then twisting
back again in the opposite direction at
the Joint they looked more like the legs
of a dog but they were far too big the
same could be said of the arms bent out
of shape at multiple points like its
legs were the creature was a mess of
misshapen limbs the cartilage and its
ears had seemingly reformed into points
and there were claws protruding from its
fingertips practically bursting out from
where a human's fingernails would be but
beneath it all and what alarmed Ranger
halter the most was its skin it had
darkened in patches layers of fur
sprouting over those areas but there
were still parts that remained clear
where skin human skin was still visible
peeling away to reveal the new fur
coated layer underneath it looked like a
grotesque accident like something ripped
straight out of an old horror movie the
kind of monster that a mad scientist
would make by halfhazard splicing DNA
and playing God hter checked the
tranquilizer gun in his trembling
fingers still empty after that most
recent shot he reached for another Dart
slowly sliding it into the loading
mechanism and readying the pistol it
cocked and made a sound the creature's
malformed head turned snapping directly
towards the source of the noise directly
towards halter he turned to Sprint away
trying to expand the distance between
him and it if he was too close the dart
wouldn't have enough momentum when he
pulled the trigger the toa's boot
snagged on something solid unmoving a
root from the tree he'd been hiding
behind he felt himself tumbled Landing
with a hard thud against the forest
floor his gun it had fallen from his
grasp he scrabbled around in the dirt
for it barely able to see where the
tranquilizer had landed in the dark just
as his fingertips brush past something
metal hter felt the force of something
heavy strike is back again this time
though it wasn't a tree it was the
creature it snarled nashing its canned
Jaws that were protruding out of its
skull rows of sharp teeth that had
uprooted the old ones bearing themselves
into the park ranger's neck and not
letting go until he'd stopped moving for
good a few short hours later a convoy of
mysterious unmarked Vehicles arrived at
gler National Park the rest of the park
rangers who had reported the strange
activity were approached by shadowy
figures who refuse to give their names
or offer up any form of identification
other than just referring to themselves
as experts in things like this not long
after none of the others would remember
Ranger halter or the incident that had
led to his untimely death after
administering amnestics it didn't take
the SCP Foundation search party long to
discover a lone coyote sniffing around
the remains of a park ranger covered in
blood the wild animal was captured to be
brought back for testing before being
re-released into the the wild meanwhile
the foundation scoured the rest of the
area until they came across the real
culprit standing in a clearing a short
distance from a foot path through the
forest was SCP
1579 of course the next challenge was
getting it packed up and transported to
biosite 66 without touching it to the
untrained I SCP 1579 looks to be fairly
unassuming even as far as anomalous
objects go it is simply an old wooden
sculpture the kind that can even be
occasionally found in various wooded
areas throughout the world its age is
Apparent from even one cursory glance at
SCP 1579 the partial damage to its Cedar
surface speaking to the numerous years
it has existed for along with the bright
green moss that covers it although
curiously this Moss doesn't seem to dry
out and die in responses to changes in
humidity nor does it affect SCP 1579
structural Integrity as for where it
came from and who made it those are
still unknown as if the answer to what
holds SCP 1579 anomalous properties
whether or not the cedar it was carved
from or the Moss coating the sculpture
possesses some unknown Properties or if
SCP 1579 was somehow imbued with these
after being created initial testing by
the SCP foundation's researchers
determined SC SCP 1579 to have an
abnormally high resistance to the type
of damage would and and particularly
cedar wood is susceptible to for one it
does not seem to show any signs of
rotting or natural degradation for
another it is also resistant to heat at
least to a certain extent it doesn't
burn the same way other objects
constructed from Cedar Wood however this
sculpture is not entirely indestructible
pieces can be easily chipped off of the
main body of SCP 1579 and these
splintered fragments continue to carry
the same anomalous effects as the rest
of the sculpture even when separate from
it but of course you want to know about
the creature how does this supposedly
harmless if a little structurally
abnormal Cedarwood sculpture connects to
whatever it was that killed park ranger
halter well it's quite simple actually
SCP 1579 killed halter not directly you
understand but by proxy through its
further anomalous properties still
confused well then how about a
demonstration let's take a look at one
of the the foundation's preferred test
subjects an Expendable member of d-class
personnel probably spending multiple
life sentences working here at the SCP
Foundation rather than behind the bars
of a maximum security institution now
what would happen if you place this
delightful individual in the same room
as SCP
1579 well nothing initially that is
until the subject touches the cedar wood
surface of the sculpture either out of
curiosity or following the inst
instructions of a foundation researcher
that's when the real anomaly starts the
wooden sculpture will exhibit a slight
but observable movement shuttering
slightly as if moved by an unseen Force
this will precede the person who touched
the object feeling a burning sensation
that kind of irritating painful heat
that spreads underneath the surface of
the skin the burning will always begin
at the area of their body that made
direct contact with SCP 1579 and
touching it again at any point point
will trigger a reactivation of the
sculptures anomalous effects subjects
experiencing the effects of SCP 1579
have describe the feeling as being akin
to a bad sunburn that rapidly spreads
Across the Skin from the point of
contact only to stop once it has
affected a person's entire body
following the subsidence of the burning
sensation subjects experiencing the side
effects of touching a CP 1579 will
notice an immediate change to Their Skin
Within a window of 3 minutes their skin
becomes thin and paperlike in its
texture before starting to peel away
once this stage occurs the peeling skin
will reveal a new layer underneath hence
the colloquially used code name for this
anomaly different skin however the
so-called different skin isn't merely a
new layer of otherwise ordinary human
skin instead it will belong to another
species entirely a person coming into
contact with SCP 1579 will find
themselves rapidly developing new skins
that shares the physical traits as well
as matching DNA to that of a number of
animal species it should be noted that
these features will continue to rapidly
develop until the subject is entirely
transformed and is no longer considered
to qualify as a human being as for the
specific transformation that occurs
there are a number of known outcomes
that repeat in the following cycle let's
say our d-class we'll call them subject
a touched as CP 1579 at the start of the
cycle they would after the burning
sensation stops and peeling begins start
to sprout dark feathers across their
torso arms and upper legs likely with a
great deal of pain as the sharp Quill of
these feathers start to burst out from
beneath the skin beneath the knees
subject a will see their legs start to
become yellow and scaly as well as a
change that causes their toenails to
Simply start to painfully protrude
outwards until they form pointed
blackened Talons subject A's face will
also start to grow fast feathers however
these grow outwards away from the areas
of the nose and mouth flight feathers
will also protrude from the forearms
multiplying in number until their entire
body is covered at which point subject a
on every level including genetically
more closely resembles a corvis korax
more commonly known as the common raven
than a human being anymore take another
test subject subject B and get them to
touch SCP 1579 right after their
different skin is covered CED in brown
fur that's approximately 4 in Long their
lips and skin underneath the fur will
darken and their nose will become
constantly moist claws will start to
grow from their fingertips although
these will be notably smaller than those
of a fully grown creature of the same
species an ursus arctos horribilis or a
grizzly bear then we get to the point in
the cycle where some unwitting hiker
encountered SCP 1579 in the forests of
Glacier National Park Montana when this
subject subject C touched the cedar
sculpture their skin began to grow
layered fur as the cartilage of their
ears is separated from their tissue and
replaced by new reshaped cartilage much
like subject B who SCP 1579 turned into
a grizzly bear subject C also had
darkened skin a moistened nose and
longer sharper Nails it was at some
point during this transformation that an
unassuming park ranger stumbled upon
subject C frightened by what he saw this
Ranger was unable to identify that what
he interpreted as attacks by some kind
of half human half animal hybrid were
actually desperate pleas for help as
subject C was transformed into a coyote
although it's hard to say which
physiological change triggered by a CP
1579 is the most alarming or unpleasant
to experience The Fourth Kind is in no
way any more pleasant than the preceding
three in the cycle subject D of this
particular series of tests will find the
new layer of skin that emerges under the
the old to be hairless and of a green
coloration often with brown markings
unlike the previous instances their skin
will rapidly begin to dry out and seems
to be far more reactive to the humidity
of the surrounding environment it is
also far thinner than that of the skin
possessed by other Transformations that
as SCP 1579 causes so thin in fact that
the eyeballs of subject D will be
visible through its eyelids which
rapidly become translucent similar to
those of the suris regula otherwise
known as the Pacific Tree Frog repeated
activation of SCP 1579 anomalous
properties will trigger the next
transformation in the cycle whether the
Cedarwood sculpture is touched by a new
subject or repeatedly by the same person
in the latter instance where a subject
is reexposed to SCP 1579 the additional
changes their body undergos will be
significantly more painful their already
newly replaced outer layer of skin will
fail to dry out and will begin bleeding
in instead three or four consecutive
exposures to SCP 1579 will lead to
excessive bodily trauma for the subject
usually causing them to die from shock
before the fourth transformation is
complete and as we're sure you can
imagine an amalgamation of a human a
raven a grizzly bear a coyote and a tree
frog is hardly a pleasant sight this
unfortunate fate was suffered during one
of the first incidents with SCP 1579
that brought the foundation's attention
to it during an elementary school field
F trip a teacher who was explaining the
history of totem poles in Native
American culture accidentally touched
SCP 1579 while experiencing the pain of
her transformation she fell against the
sculpture in a panic not realizing it
had been what caused her to change this
repeated triggering of the object's
anomalous effects led to her untimely
death an event that had to be wiped from
the minds of her students by the
foundation using the careful application
of Class B amnestics for now SCP 1579 is
kept in in a secure sterile environment
at a foundation storage Warehouse where
Personnel are not permitted to make any
contact with it so there's no need to
worry about accidentally running into
SCP 1579 in the wild although there are
always plenty of other things to worry
about while out on a hike through the
forest things that could be right behind
you so here's a statement that won't
blow anyone's mind the SCP Foundation is
really really really weird and we're not
even talking about the actual anomalies
they contain sure this top secret
organization puts in the time and the
effort to make sure menaces to society
like the heart to destroy reptile the
Scarlet King and even the horrifying bad
joke Tomatoes stay behind lock and key
but sometimes you need to hold the
mirror up to yourself and see just what
the heck is going on I mean seriously
think about it this is an organization
that uses live human beings farmed from
Death Row as test subjects considering
how rarely the death penalty is actually
employed in the Western World these days
you know some shady strings are being
pulled there and what about the 05
Council the leaders of Humanity's last
line of defense against anomalous chaos
and according to some accounts there are
a group of vain Petty and morally
bankrupt individuals who regularly use
anomalies like SCP 006 the Fountain of
Youth for their own personal benefit and
don't even get me started on the actual
scientists working under the
foundation's payroll that's when things
start getting even stranger of course
there's Dr Jack Bry a man forever
changed by the chance interaction with
SCP 963 an anomalous Medallion and one
of Abel's deadly blades now he's an
immortal weirdo who equal parts
brilliant and a total nuisance so much
so that there's an entire dedicated list
forbidding all of his xier Antics then
there's Dr Alto cleff don't even try to
shake his hand given how much this x
gooc wildcard loves using violence to
solve his problems you may draw back a
stump he specializes in reality warping
anomalies often wields a ukulele cuz
he's just so darn quirky oh and he's
very likely the baby daddy to a teenage
nature Sprite after a delance with a
goddess or oh and um what about Dr
Charles Ogden gears sure he may not look
that strange to the naked eye he's a man
so dull and humorous that gray is his
favorite color and he thinks sugar on
corn flakes is an act of unacceptable
decadence but he's got a whole lot of
strangeness under the hood like the fact
he's such an emotionally unavailable
father that his daughters across
Dimensions have formed a Splinter Cell
of the Serpent's hand where they work
under the collective pseudonym The Black
Queen just to spite him Dr Dan through
acts of sabotage was personally
responsible for the worst scp096
outbreak in Foundation history leading
to the end of thousands of lives just so
he could receive clearance to terminate
the creature and he got that clearance
on the condition that the SCP Foundation
would be terminating him for his crimes
as soon as the goal is achieved and then
there's oh my God
did someone dress a dog up in scientist
clothes oh my God that's the cutest
thing I've ever seen oh this is just
bright my day okay maybe I was being too
harsh on the foundation before who whose
dog is this excuse me sir that is
extremely inappropriate wait you can
talk of course I can talk you ad I'm
Professor Kan pathos Crow one of the SCP
foundation's finest Minds in the field
of advanced Robotics and biochemistry I
have a level four clearance for 3436 I'm
not some common bloody mut oh my
apologies Professor Crow I wasn't aware
you were a well a talking dog well yes I
imagine there's a lot you don't know
about me isn't there um I'm a little
embarrassed to admit it but uh that's
true Professor Crow our data on you and
your work with the SCP Foundation is a
little sparse here take these files
these should give you a good primer okay
I suppose we better take this from the
top then Professor cath those Crow among
a lineup of extremely eccentric
researchers somehow manages to rise to
the very top in terms of sheer
strangeness to get the most obvious fact
out of the way yes while he was once a
human an anomalous experiment did result
in him being turned into a Labrador
Retriever how did this happen you may
ask we have the same question sadly
Professor Crow is incredibly reluctant
to share any details about this strange
and embarrassing incident so we're just
going to have to accept it for what it
is and move on everyone ready
okay good despite his strange appearance
Professor Crow is actually one of the
more scientifically qualified of the
foundation researchers it's no surprise
that because of this he has a relatively
close working relationship with Dr gears
so much so that he still refers to gears
by his early Foundation code name Cog a
reference to both the legendary Stern
doctor's initials and a pun on his
iconic surname during one incident Dr
gears did tell Professor Crow to
terminate an anomaly that was was for
all intents and purposes a human child
if it presented any difficulties this
sour the wholesomeness of that previous
fact so we'll swiftly move on once again
Dr gears is just terrible with kids like
a lot of foundation researchers
Professor Crow was personally head
hunted by the SCP Foundation after his
academic work in the fields of advanced
Robotics and biochemistry started
Turning Heads This was just for clarity
sake back before Professor Crow was
turned into a laborator professor Crow
spends most of his time working in
bioarch area 12 where he studies a
variety of anomalies but his bookish
nature also earned him another
interesting position he's the SCP
foundation's Chief librarian where his
encyclopedic knowledge of anomalous
technical literature has made him a
valuable asset in archiving and
organization this balances out some of
Professor Crow's indiscretions it is
important to specify that Professor Crow
is genuinely a well-liked figure among
his SCP Foundation co-workers after all
who wouldn't love to work with an
adorable dog in a lab coat and glasses
all day but it's also important to note
that he is also somewhat mistaken prone
with a number of these mistakes putting
him in the crosshairs of his superiors
Professor Crow has come close to
outright termination several times
perhaps the most out of any prominent
researcher currently working at the
foundation however to keep himself out
of the same Dead Man Walking category
that the thoroughly unpleasant Dr Dan
currently finds himself in Professor
Crow has a few aces up his sleeve
firstly he's got friends in the
administrative Department willing to
pull a few strings to keep him out of
Harm's Way hey maybe they're just very
Ardent dog lovers up there the other
thing that's kept him from being turned
into an extremely overqualified chew toy
for SCP 682 is the contents of His
Brilliant brain on many of the occasions
where the 05 Council have considered
terminating him he's demonstrated the
fact he possesses vital and often
Irreplaceable knowledge saving his furry
skin a perfect example of the kinds of
strange scrapes that Professor Crow gets
himself into is the incident in 2009
where without even realizing it he
somehow traveled through time and scared
The Living Daylights out of everyone the
details are best expressed here in
Professor Crow's own dictated notes 18
out2 2009 in all my years working here
there have been few things which have
irritated me caus me physical harm yes
caus me undo stress yes caus me
innumerable amount of mental distress
yes but few things have just irritated
me time travel is one of them I went to
bed on the 15th of January year 2009 at
1:30 a.m. I woke up on February 18th at
9:26 a.m. of the same year I hadn't
moved I had only 9 hours of sleep and to
me nothing had happened then after a
slightly confused day admidst the many
cries of I thought you were dead among
other things I might add I discovered
that I have been missing for the past
month and 3 days in that time Sophia had
completely taken over my duties though
she had halted all of my personal
experiments and was trying her utmost to
relocate me while keeping my
disappearance from the hups Apparently
data expunged leaving me to sleep in a
small self-contained bubble of data
expunged and making at least data
expunged which was eventually ruptured
by data expunged and sending me back to
this phase of space and time needless to
say I was slightly irritated to say the
least 2402 2009
ah they've had me in quarantine for
nearly the past week observing me and
running tests to see if they can find
any sort of strange abnormalities with
my physiology my behavior my anything if
I had one more hand shoved up my nether
regions or forced to look at one more
bloody ink blot I'm going to flip out
and go rabid they'll say they'll stop
the quarantine soon and Sophia says the
higher-ups still haven't caught on to
anything I suppose I'm lucky in that
count normally the only time they
quarantine something is when it's too
dead to be any sort of IM immediate
security Hazard still I guess I can see
where they're coming from if it were my
decision I'd probably force a quarantine
too and probably for longer at least
they had the decency to give me my
clothes my PDA and someone to dictate to
1203 2009 I'm still here and I hate it
day in day out it's the same thing get
up eat exercise then simple observation
until lunch then more observation until
dinner then lights out not allowed
anything other than the things I already
have and even then I only got those
because Sophia felt bad for me I'm only
allowed to use them every day for an
hour at most otherwise they're also in
observational storage all this wasted
time that I could have been doing
something constructive something useful
something interesting but no I'm stuck
here because of a r twist of fate
forcing me into this monotonous hell
they keep telling me I'll be let out
soon Liars 055 2009 they've seen fit to
release me I almost thought I was going
to die in there still it almost seems
strange to be out and about again but I
do appreciate being back in my own
quarters my own clothes and my beloved
Walker back by my side Sophia's Taken
good care of the facility while I was
gone I think I might actually leave that
to her while I keep to my experiments
she seems to enjoyed a great deal suits
her analytical mind all of my personal
experiments are still waiting for me
with the exception of the 040 test logs
they simply haven't posted their
findings yet stating that they needed my
approval first so I'll have to pour
through those the first chance I get I'm
interested in the progress she may have
made still there is a good deal of work
to be done and I am more than ready
enough to take it on after all I have to
make up for lost time don't I it's clear
that life isn't easy for poor Professor
Crow much like Dr brigh After
experiencing the mysterious event that
turned him into a dog Professor Crow is
both a researcher and an anomaly and
unlike the superficially subtle
presentation of Dr Bright's anomalous
nature it's hard to hide the strangeness
of a talking dog in human clothes this
bizarre interatial Zone he occupies
forces the foundation to keep him on an
extremely short leash no pun intended
seriously Professor it wasn't intended I
swear anyway the point is Professor Crow
isn't allowed to clock off at the end of
the workday like his fellow researchers
do he's forced to remain on site almost
never appearing in public if the
professor wasn't the kind of person who
could easily get lost in his work a
situation like this would probably drive
him into saying speaking of you're
probably wondering by this point other
than being the cutest researcher at the
foundation sorry Dr clef you're special
in your own way we promise what kind of
work is Professor Cain pathos Crow
actually known for around here Professor
Crow's most notable body of work is
largely based on an opinion that's
pretty controversial to hold around the
SCP Foundation he believes that they
should be actively utilizing anomalies
that aren't dangerous in order to
further their Collective goals an
excellent example of this is The Cordial
relationship he has with SCP 040 also
known as Evolution's child she's a
powerful reality warper who was able to
synthesize new anomalous life from
pre-existing living creatures Professor
Crow who refers to her as Emma in his
personal writings was initially training
her to do this with SCP 148 the infamous
telekill alloy however he also filed a
formal request to go further saying I
think it's about time we started trying
to utilize 4 Z's abilities or at the
very least allowing her to use them
enough to actually learn how to control
them she will not be able to rely on the
SCP 148 hair pieces forever we theorize
that as she gets older her powers will
increase exponentially possibly to the
point where her unconscious telepathy
cannot be contained he also somewhat
infamously went ham with a series of
experiments using SCP 158 a frightening
anomalous device known as the soul
extractor which contrary to its name
Professor Crow also realized could place
removed Souls into other objects or
creatures this led to the creation of a
being that Crow dubbed zero because it
was subject zero in his experiments to
create a composite Soul using SCP 158 he
spoke of this subject somewhat creepily
in his notes zero would make an
excellent candidate for my assistant it
respects and admires me for its creation
much as a child would an endearing
father figure I have assured it that it
would be treated well and that I would
give it a host to the best of my ability
to create all that it asks of me is that
it be given a name other than zero a
name not a number I told it to give
itself a name to chren itself whatever
it so wishes it told me it would have to
think about it like a lot of strange and
fascinating figures everything you learn
about Professor Cain pathos Crow seems
to raise new questions is Crow just a
mad scientist Without a Cause eager to
perform bizarre experiments for their
own sake well not not quite the sum
total of all of Professor Crow's work is
Project Olympia a topic that probably
deserves a whole video in its own right
and do sound off in the comments if
you'd like to hear more about the
deranged Frankenstein Project that
Professor Crow has devoted his life to
you see project Olympia is Crow's baby
and also his attempt to play God through
combining a variety of different
anomalies including all the ones we've
mentioned here and several others he
would hope to create an entirely
artificial living thing that would serve
the interests of the SCP Foundation how
exactly this would be beneficial to the
SCP Foundation is admittedly a little
confusing but seeing this goal through
to its conclusion has become an
all-consuming obsession for Professor
KRA he's performed countless experiments
with a huge catalog of anomalies under
the project Olympia umbrella he's
written Rams upon reams of notes and
logs on the subject and produced a huge
number of prototypes he's also used
project Olympia as a pretense to remove
even more Souls using a SCP 158 because
that just appears to be a strange
obsession of his doesn't it incidentally
we aren't the only ones confused about
the exact purpose and value of project
Olympia when members of the 05 Council
finally got a proper look at Professor
Crow's work with the project they
released the following statement all
activity related to project Olympia has
been discontinued OverWatch command has
deemed it to be a gross waste of
resources and permanently removed
support for the project with Personnel
assigned to work with it being moved to
Alternative sites a hearing is to be
held with the project ad administrators
to determine how the project was able to
continue as long as it did despite the
lack of any concrete results prototypes
and other equipment have been slated to
be decommissioned Professor Crow took
this news about as well as you could
expect but in the end he always finds a
way to wriggle out and continue doing
whatever he wants to do because that's
what Professor Cain pathos Crow is all
about he's living proof that sometimes
he just can't keep a good dog down in an
old house an old woman gathers her
knitting supplies
this is a special project for a little
boy named Tommy she loves dearly she
knits furiously and soon the mix of
cotton synthetic fiber and cloth of
every color turned from raw materials
into something else a teddy bear she
puts the finishing touches on the bear
this is a very special bear after all
and sends the patchwork bear off to its
destination with a red get well card the
card is labeled Kos the bear and inside
she writes a personal note to Tommy
because only time can mend all wounds
love Grammy but this package of Love
would never reach its destination SCP
2295 was found at the site of a crashed
mail truck and it looks exactly like a
standard handmade teddy bear with one
difference on the left side of its chest
just under its jawy tan bow it wears a
heart-shaped pin but not a standard
cartoon heart this is a disturbingly
realistic anatomically correct pin of a
heart organ and that's because SCP 2295
has a specific purpose and it's one that
has everything to do with actual human
organs SCP 2295 spends most of its time
completely inert spending its days as
just another cuddly stuffed toy tests
performed on the toy revealed that it
had no unusual properties and seems to
be a normal handmade Keepsake that is
until someone is injured in its presence
not any injury will do a paper cut or
even a broken arm for example won't do
much to activate its anomalous
properties but if it detects a critical
injury to a human organ nearby it will
trigger a secret power one that the
foundation is still trying to figure out
how it works because SCP
2295 is a miracle worker when it senses
the presence of someone with a serious
injury to an organ and is within 2 m of
them SCP 2295 Springs into action
suddenly from unknown sources the bear
will produce objects including scissors
white thread and sewing needles or a
crocheting hook from its mouth if there
are any crafting supplies on hand it
will incorporate those as well and then
it gets to work despite only having
hands made of fabric and stuffing with
no fingers the anomalous Bearer is still
able to craft what will end up being a
patchwork Recreation of the damaged
humans organ cute if a little creepy but
that's just the beginning the injured
person mysteriously Falls unconscious
and the patchwork organ which the
foundation has designated as SCP 22951
instance will disappear the SCP 22 95-1
instance will then physically replace
the damaged organ inside the person's
body it's unknown how this happens the
patchwork organ will simply appear
inside of their body taking the place of
the original lung or kidney or whichever
organ was failing it's unknown where the
original organ goes to since it's it
seems to just disappear as soon as the
22 95-1 instance takes its place
surprisingly having this new cotton
stuffed harder liver does not seem to
cause any harm and in fact it works
exactly like the real thing there are
never any of the usual issues that come
with a transplant like the risk of it
being rejected by the body as the
organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating
it like it was there all along in all
instances of SCP 2295 performing this
adorable but rudimentary surgery the
subjects have made a full and complete
recovery SCP 2295 might sound like a
miracle worker but that isn't to say
that its abilities aren't without their
own set of complications when faced with
two injured subjects SCP 2295 seems to
always gravitate towards fixing the
younger subject up first maybe owing to
its creation by a grandmother who wanted
to heal whatever was ailing her grandson
no one knows who Tommy was or exactly
what disease or injury he was recovering
from but his grandmother clearly felt it
was serious enough to create this
special bear for him while SCP 2295 will
heal anyone it seems to be primarily a
guardian for the young and it takes its
duties very seriously even to the point
of self sacrifice while SCP 2295 is able
to pull some of its supplies out of thin
air it still always needs some raw
materials to craft the new organ
including Fabric and stuffing and if
there are none available
SC SCP 2295 will obtain them the hard
way the patchwork bear will sacrifice
its own body tearing itself open and
removing any Fabric or stuffing it needs
without any concern for its own
well-being in order to craft a new organ
for its patient it slowly regenerates
its own stuffing at the rate of around a
gram of stuffing per day but it needs to
harvest fabric to repair its outer layer
which the foundation happily makes
available to it offering it a variety of
of patterns and types it's no surprise
that a teddy bear capable of healing
mortal wounds would be of great interest
to the SCP Foundation and as soon as it
was recovered from the crash mail truck
they immediately began tests to find out
more about it could it heal literally
any organ were there any limits to its
abilities there was only one way to find
out and the foundation had the perfect
test subjects d-class Personnel whose
interactions with non cuddly teddy bear
SCP frequently left them with critical
external and internal injuries the first
test subject brought in D 2353 a
38-year-old man who was in poor health
not due to his work as a d-class
Personnel but from his years and years
of heavy smoking his lungs were
seriously damaged which gave him trouble
breathing and made any serious physical
exertion extremely difficult he wasn't
critically injured or in danger of dying
immediately but that didn't matter to
p2295 D 2353 quickly passed out and the
bear sprang into action it proceeded to
take two textile swatches one black and
one red and create a pair of fabric
lungs which had installed in the patient
when he awoke d235 I found he had full
healthy lung function again as if he
never picked up his deadly habit but now
the foundation researchers needed to
know how SCP 2295 would do with even
more complicated ailments
d354 was 50 years old and his heart was
not in good shape not only did he have a
serious case of
atherosclerosis which is a disease where
cholesterol plaque builds up and blocks
blood flow and can put you at serious
risk of a heart attack but he also had
an irregular heartbeat this d-class was
in bad shape but that was no problem for
SCP 2295 who took a collection of
different colors of yarn and a crochet
hook and created a plushy heart just
like the lungs had acted as if they were
completely regular organs after the
heart anomalously ended up inside the
man's chest it began to beat normally
and performed all the complicated
functions of a human heart but there was
one detail that shocked the onlooking
doctors before the yarn organ had
vanished the doctors had seen that it
was beating so is there any organ that
SC SCP 2295 can't replace that was about
to be tested when
d789 was brought in a 24-year-old woman
she had suffered serious Burns all over
her torso left abdomen and right leg she
was brought in and sedated to numb the
agonizing pain and researchers were
worried that they had come up against
the limit of SCP 2295 abilities since
the skin is the largest organ after all
but SCP 2295 wasn't phased at all the
bear immediately started sewing segments
of Patchwork Fabric and layering them
onto the damaged skin repl replacing the
dermis and epidermis layer by layer
unlike the other cases these replacement
organs are visible and D 7894 now has
Patchwork skin just like her talented
surgeon and amazingly the fabric has the
same sense of touch that her regular
skin did the final test of SCP 2295
civilities came with d
2723 who was only 18 years old this last
minute d-class test was performed
because he was showing signs of severe
cerebral hemorrhage the kind that would
cause brain damage in only minutes and
would be followed soon after by complete
brain death SCP 2295 sprung to life but
as soon as it examined the test subject
it became distressed it started
frantically grasping at random material
around it as if it didn't know what to
do with them then it reached inside
itself and provided a large chocolate
bar which had offered to the subject
sadly to no effect it then seemed to
admit defeat as it grabbed tightly onto
the subject's leg observers reported
that it was leaking a tear-like solution
from its small knitted eyes as it
embrace the dying declass in his final
moments sadly it seems that the human
brain is the one mystery that even SCP
2295 can't solve SC SCP 2295 appears to
pose no threat to anyone and was
classified as safe after testing it is
inactive when not in the presence of an
injured person and has never displayed
hos instincts when active the foundation
determined that it should be stored in a
standard containment Locker in site 37
where it can be kept safely until it's
needed for tests or to repair an injured
SCP Personnel access is limited to those
with level three or higher security
clearance and any contact with the bear
is highly regulated but there is one
element of SCP 2295 existence that
continues to worry Foundation staff SCP
2295 is full Origins and the grandmother
who crafted it are unknown the note it
was found with is the only clue as to
where it may have come from but there
are plenty within the foundation who are
suspicious of the veracity of this
letter and they have good reason not to
be too trusting because another bear
with similar abilities exists and it is
distinctly less benevolent than SCP
2295 SCP 1048 is also a teddy bear but
it is capable of moving on its own and
communicating through gestures at all
times it was initially allowed to wander
around independently and seemed to make
its home at site 24 a happier place but
then it began to display its own
crafting abilities SCP 1048 is able to
craft duplicates of itself and while the
original was seemingly harmless the ones
it made were not these similarly shaped
bears were made of disturbing materials
and were extremely hostile towards any
humans they encountered the first first
SCP
1048-a was made entirely out of human
ears and when it shrieked it caused
anyone nearby to generate ear-like
growths all over their bodies eventually
causing them to suffocate the creature
disappeared and an on-site researcher
was found to be missing an ear the
creations of SCP 1048 only got stranger
and deadlier from there SCP 1048-b was
found in the SES cafeteria where it was
moving around in a halted jerky fashion
it then started bursting at the seams
and revealed what appeared to be a human
fetus inside when the creature screamed
it sounded like a much louder version of
a human infant and its crows caused
Massive Internal damage to anyone around
it SCP 1048-b was killed in the ensuing
conflict with Foundation agents ending
its threat but SCP 1048 was learning
deadlier techniques when SCP 1048 C was
discovered it looked to be a teddy bear
made in entirely out of Rusty scrap
metal when it was spotted by Dr Carver
and targeted by Foundation Personnel the
creature turned violent and proved to
have Incredible strength jumping through
the agents who were trying to neutralize
it tearing through their bodies like
tissue paper attempts to damage it were
unsuccessful and both it and the bear
made out of ears are still on the loose
along with the original SCP 1048
capturing it is Major priority for the
foundation because no one wants to see
what it will create next is there a
connection between these two very
different teddy bears no one has been
able to answer this question the origins
of SCP 1048 are unknown and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made Kos the bear but their
abilities are similar with both able to
craft living objects out of seemingly
any material they just have very
different ideas as to what a good use of
their crafting abilities are it is
fortunate that an anomaly as potentially
powerful as SCP 2295 seems to only want
one thing to help those in need
especially those who are the most
vulnerable You're a child awake at night
what a feeling in your room you cling to
these rare hours of the evening and
watch the hour hand crawl closer towards
the parts of the clock you've never seen
touched now you stare out your window
embracing the moon the stars and the
Darkness that engulfs them you trace an
owl's hooh hoos up towards the densest
Evergreen in the neighborhood you see a
rat Scurry across the top of a brick
wall you wave to your new nocturnal
friends bonded by the preference of
night now you open your window and
inhale smelling the dark sky like
chocolate cake you hold it in as long as
you can very soon you know it will all
be taken from you not by a God or a
black hole or any of the the universe's
hypothesize collapses at this age you
know nothing of physical cosmology you
know nothing of the Book of Revelation
you're just a child the forces that give
and take from you are not understood
through physics nor philosophy nor
through numbers nor thought experiments
look at you your thumb is still pruned
from having just kicked the habit of
sucking it your pajamas are still one
unified piece of clothing cradling your
entire with fuzzy cotton your teddy bear
is still an extension of your arm not
yet removed by maturity you're still
another 15 years from believing your
life is dictated by astrological signs
or personal free will or mathematical
outputs it's not that you're ignorant in
fact you're quite bright as a child you
don't bother to comprehend the forces
outside your house because you know as
long as you are living inside it they
have no governance the only true comes
from with within from the two Gods you
have seen with your very own eyes
sitting on the ripped sofa in Gray
sweatpants watching a show about rich
people drinking mimosas on boats in the
Mediterranean the almighty parents
rulers of everything and with just one
compound word called up the stairs they
have the power to take everything away
from you bed time and suddenly the
curtains are pulled over the world you
long for now it's not the stars but the
ceiling you're staring at but thankfully
You are not alone you pull your teddy
bear out from its hibernation beneath
your armpit and you hug him gently
careful not to squeeze out his stuffing
laying there you can't help but wonder
how your bear got like this so beaten
and bruised torn up like a dog toy one
eye dangling from a string his left leg
bends forward impersonating The Joint
structures of a flamingo yet as far as
you know your best pal has done nothing
but sleep how is is he so battered can
hibernation be that taxing do teddy
bears expire the questions for now must
be ignored you lay there together in
your bed fighting the feelings of
Slumber almost as if rebelling against
Mom and Dad's tyranny thinking deeply
only makes you sleepier and tonight you
insist on staying awake it's 9:30 and
you've yet to be sucked into a dream and
that in itself is a small victory but
your parents' wishes will not be evaded
that easily if ever they fight back by
turning on the air conditioning the soft
rhythmic humming of the White Noise
weighs on your eyes and soon you can't
resist it any longer sleep sneaks up on
you the Battle Is Lost a safe 10 minutes
later your parents poke their heads into
your room and see your body stiff and
motionless wrapped in sheets like a
mummy they celebrate their Victory with
a quick kiss and go back to the sofa to
rest like Gods on the seventh day and
While You Were Sleeping dream dreaming
of a tomorrow where you don't surrender
to the same Powers there is yet another
battle to be fought and if all goes well
you'll sleep right through it but some
children won't be so lucky on July 7th
2001 a Portland Oregon news headline
reported a young boy missing from home
in the middle of the night his parents
were quick to respond that their son
wasn't the type of boy to go wandering
out into the dark and that something
suspicious was sure to be discovered
there in his bedroom the first thing
noticed was his stuffed animal a joke
Orca torn to shreds its stuffing
scattered across the carpet its head and
body were stationed in the corner
nearest the bed soaked in a black
substance similar to Ink its eyes damp
with water the boy however was not to be
found as the parents held their son's
dismantled Orca in their hands feeling
the weight of mortality they combed
their fingers through the stuffed
animals organs as if giving it an
impromptu autopsy trying to determine
what kind of Beast could have done this
but it wasn't Justice for the Orca they
were after by the time we are old enough
to be parents we've outgrown empathy for
our inanimate counterparts for them the
Orca was simply a representation of the
cruel faith that may have also been
bestowed on their child its death was
only respected for how it related to the
living and so the poor Ora was set aside
forgotten about until investigators
called upon the foundation to intervene
at which point MTF Iota 12 were
dispatched it revealed that the young
boy's room had large Trails of viscous
black liquid streaking the walls the
very same liquid found on the Orca but
where did this liquid come from
unfortunately there was no camera
footage to give us the answer neither
were there eyewitness reports or any
residual signs of what specifically
occurred neighbors who were awake
reported hearing the Thump Thump
thumping from the room which as expected
was useless by standard Insight leading
to nothing more than a series of rumors
and speculations maybe was an extremely
localized earthquake maybe he was just
throwing a temper tantrum but where does
maybe this maybe that lead us to can
factual answers ever come from this
level of uncertainty well one specific
maybe just maybe the key to cracking
this case allow me to explain 2 days
after the event the child was
rediscovered unconscious behind a hedge
in the family's Garden a brief interview
revealed that the child witnessed the
final minutes of what he described as an
intense battle he claimed my Orca was
fighting a big monster and then the
monster grabbed me and took me out the
window but someone saw it so it dropped
me and I hid in the bush a second
interview revealed no other discoveries
but the child claimed that the monster
ate his socks initial reactions to the
two interviews were as expected adults
reason the claims were imaginary a
fabrication of the child's mind
manifested to protect himself from
whatever the real trauma endured
actually was but heard beneath the
skeptical murmurs of jaded grown-ups
enslaved by their narrow perceptions was
one individual who dared to suggest
maybe just maybe the boy is telling the
truth and it was in the spirit of this
hopeful and trusting maybe that the
foundation would prove the boy's story
to be truth and the truth would be known
as SCP
6330 SC SCP 6330 is a phenomenon
affecting stuffed animals worldwide
though it is most common in Bears
manifestation of this phenomenon is
referred to as a sleepwalker event
occurring only within the households of
families with young children typically
between the ages of 1 to 14 while you're
asleep vulnerable to what lingers awake
your favorite stuffed animal may find
life impulsively combating enemies
referred to as SCP 6330 D2 these
creatures typically blend with shadows
though this mechanism is poorly
understood they somewhat resemble
creatures associated with fantasy such
as dragons or ogres always manifesting
beneath your bed no matter how messy or
clean it might be SCP 63302 instances
depict Behavior indicating that they
intend to hurt or prey upon the sleeping
child and it isn't nightlights or
security systems that stop them but
rather SCP 6330 d1s SCP 63301 are
stuffed animals already present in a
child's room that seem to be
nonanomalous prior to SCP
63302 manifestations SCP 63301 has been
shown to instantaneously manifest small
wooden Weaponry in order to combat SCP
63302 to protect their child battles
have been shown to last upwards of 20
minutes and are always near silent there
is an unspoken agreement between both
sides to keep their history concealed as
best as they can in observed cases SCP
63301 have emerged Victorious though are
severely wounded during the Skirmish
torn wool and stuffing are common and
following all known events SCP 63301
have died due to their injuries but only
after sacrificing themselves for the
safety of the child prior to death the
instance will drag the SCP 6330 d2's
corpse back under the bed frame and Dem
manifest to understand this the
foundation has conducted just one test
given the volatile nature of recreating
the events the foundation did not push
their luck with subsequent studies and
so it's the lone research done in 1987
on site 44 that they still lean on to
this day to understand SCP 6330 and the
instances that come with it it began
with a researcher volunteering his
7-year-old daughter henceforth referred
to as subject to be placed in a humanoid
containment room and sooth to sleep
using a teddy bear that she had a strong
emotional attachment to for 12 straight
tests our subject was observed to sleep
through the night peacefully her
environment remaining in alignment with
the trivialities of deep sleep but on
the 13th study something would happen
something very unsettling even for the
foundation standards MTF Iota 12 were
stationed at the room's entrance for
Swift intervention if needed and until
that 13th attempt they felt their focus
to be pointless approaching the third
hour however they felt a subtle and
unexplained value in their presence they
felt something coming on that feeling
while danger is looming that feeling
that makes you clench your fists just in
case and just as they made eye contact
with one another to acknowledge this
shared feeling within the group a quiet
rustling sound Was Heard beneath the bed
and sounds reminiscent of a large
animal's breathing became audible
suddenly a pair of large scaly clawed
hands grasp the rim of the bed frame a
creature resembling a western Dragon
emerged but was it actually a dragon
were the sheets ready to be blasted to
flames if slain would the next regrow
and multiply by the hundreds these
thoughts raced through MTF Iota 12's
head one member instinctually ran for
the door to go protect the child but he
was held back and restrained reminded
that the success of the experiment was
dependent on letting the situation play
out naturally it was hard to console
patience at this moment did not feel
like a virtue it felt irresponsible a
creature standing approxim IM 3 m above
the ground switching between bipedal and
quadrapedal motion was stalking a
sleeping child and they were instructed
to Simply watch for 5 minutes the SCP
6330 D2 patrolled the room moving
silently and methodically unaware of the
surveillance cameras then SCP 63302
turned towards the subject positioning
itself at the foot of the bed stretching
its arms out towards the subject it
gaped its jaws wide exposing in rows of
large pointed teeth and a dark pink
tongue it looked like a snake in a field
of mice as it prepared to Lunge at the
subject MTF Iota 12 was ready to
intervene but before they could the
stuffed bear stood up on the subject's
chest and Drew a small sword and shield
from an unknown source almost magically
like switching weapons in an old Zelda
video game it positioned its swords
tipped downward and held its Shield at
its side SCP
63301 hunched over slight L and twirled
its sword maintaining eye contact with
SCP
63302 the entire way through after 10
seconds the SCP 6330 D2 threw its jaws
at the subject and SCP 63301 responds
with a leap towards the subject's
attacker slicing SCP 6330 d2's eye the
SCP 63302 responds with a quiet Grunt
and touches its wound which leaks a
viscous black liquid the SCP 63301 jumps
towards SCP
63302 and mid battle uses fabric from
the bed sheets to quickly Stitch the
wound attempting to minimize mess and
proof of its presence both instances
went to battle for 9 minutes before the
first signs of damage to SCP
63301 following the severing of one of
SCP 6330 d2's dorsal spikes it strikes
the SCP 63301 with a heavy slap which
sends SCP
63301 across the room it stands back up
placing a hand on its stomach and looks
at its hand which is now covered in wool
and stuffing they charge at each other
once again but as the subject moves
slightly in her sleep both instances
stop and quickly agree on peace until
the subject settles when that happens
the instances resume fighting research
notes that while the battle is genuine
there is an element of guidance they do
not follow a script but it appears they
follow a code while both anomalies
welcome the conflict brought on by the
other neither wants it broadcasted to
the public after 20 minutes of battle
both instances are heavily scarred and
injured after kicking itself off of the
SCP 6330 d2's nose SCP 63301 Sprints
from one side of the room towards SCP
63302 leaping into the air and Landing a
fatal blow slicing the neck of the other
instance which Falls lifeless to the
floor SCP 63302 is dragged by the SCP
63301 back under the bed a short while
later the SCP 63301 emerges damage
sustained includes loss of one buttoned
eye exposed stuffing and torn wool it
places its sword and broken shield on a
nearby nightstand SCP 63301 then drags
itself up the bed sheets towards the
subject who was sleeping peacefully
throughout the test it rests beside the
child lying motionless it seems to glare
directly at the camera and a small digit
protrudes from its round hand giving a
thumbs up to the researchers its head
flops onto the child's cheek before it
ceases to move the father who rised his
daughter for research is pleased with
the discoveries regarding both anomalies
but it brings about a new set of
questions concerning children and their
relationship with the dark these very
thoughts you might even wonder yourself
maybe a kid's desire to stay up past
bedtime isn't so much about wanting to
watch cartoons with curs wordss or Reed
Calvin and Hobs maybe it's not about a
desire to be awake at all but rather a
subconscious fear of being asleep maybe
our senses as children are heightened to
the anomalies that creep about maybe all
the fabled fears of children aren't
fairy tales after all and maybe Mom and
Dad checking under our bed is just
performance parenting because even if
something were there would they even be
able to see it or is everything Beyond
an adult's understanding misattributed
to the imagination as we age does our
perception of how reality should look
alter the reality that is actually there
do we indeed see clearer with our
expensive glasses from our high-rise
office space or did we see more
accurately in the glow of our action
figure NightLight spying through
stitches in our blankets looking past
crusty eye boogers at what moved in the
shadows it is hard to ever know for
every real encounter a child has with an
SCP 6330 there might be hundreds of
falsehoods the ratio is truly impossible
to calculate but as long as teddy bears
are Universal so too are there anomalous
enemies and so where does that fact
leave us how do we go forward should we
be afraid to put our children to sleep
afraid of the monsters under their bed I
don't think that's what our hero would
want sometimes we have to learn to trust
things even if we don't understand them
like gravity or multiplication we have
to trust that the relationship ship
between children and their stuffed
animals are in fact real we have to
learn their loyalty is reciprocated even
if the adult world has taught us
otherwise and if we ever need a reminder
of these lessons we can look to event
184 in Cambridge England where we have
our first recording of a sleepwalker
event outside of controlled testing and
also our first piece of evidence proving
SCP
63301 to understand language and how to
use it to connect with humans in ways
Beyond being cute and cuddly on November
11th 2008 a call was filed to local
authorities by a family who claimed to
have discovered footage of a sleepwalker
event within their son's room mobile
task force Iota 12 lucid dreamers were
dispatched to investigate immediately
the footage was seized by personnel and
all members of the family were
administered Class A amnestics the
child's bed swayed lightly as an
instance of SCP 6330 two emerges the
instance resembles an unknown creature
though it is described as having a large
muscular frame the instance walks to the
opposite end of the room hunching over
and observing the child for exactly 10
minutes as the SCP 63302 begins to stand
further upright it extends a retractable
set of claws then the child's teddy bear
suddenly stands drawing a bow and quiver
SCP 63302 assumes a quadrapedal stance
and snarls before lunging towards the
bed the SCP 63301 fires a single Arrow
towards the SCP
63302 striking the instance directly in
its canine like snout SC SCP 63302
responds with a loud Huff reminiscent of
that of a bull or Bine the instances
battle for approximately 30 minutes the
longest recorded Sleepwalker event to
date both show abilities and skill sets
consistent with other SCP 6330 D1 and-2
instances
eventually SCP
63302 has SCP 63301 pinned to a nearby
wall and tries to strangle it the SCP
63302 then pulls one of SCP 6330 d1's
arrows from its arm plunging it into the
Das one's chest then the dash2 leans its
head towards the dash1 and Whispers into
the instance's right ear though audio
recordings cannot determine exactly what
was vocalized the SCP 63301 lifts up its
head staring blankly into SCP 6330 d2's
eyes it reaches behind its back pulling
out a small entirely wooden Glock 19
handgun the bear points the weapon into
SCP 6330 d2's forehead and fires the
shot is silent and the SCP 6330 d2's
body falls limp black viscous fluid
sprays onto the wall the SCP 63301 hauls
SCP 6330 d2's corpse Towards the bed
noticeably limping it drags the body by
its large forearm and Dem manifests upon
reaching the underneath of the bed SCP
63301 returns and briefly stares around
the room before turning to the child it
climbs up a desk and finds a piece of
paper and a pen it goes on to write the
following note hello Timothy thank you
for always taking care of me it really
was fun I was able to repay the favor of
protecting you unfortunately I am hurt I
need to go I'm too weak to stay
and I just hope you'll remember me it's
been fun helping you I've enjoyed my
time under your care going into this I
knew it would happen the Sleepwalker is
coming for you I'm just happy I could do
my job goodbye my friend I hope I may
see you soon it has been often said that
dog is man's best friend and obviously
that isn't just exclusive to men ask any
pet owner whether they own a dog cat
rabbit hamster or soul sucking
interdimensional parasitic monster with
too many tentacles and they'll all tell
you the same your pet can be your best
friend they can give you the most
unconditional affectionate form of love
possible and as long as you treat your
little buddy right they'll be loyal to
you for the rest of your life and theirs
it's not uncommon for a pet to outlive
their owner especially if they belong to
someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some
although though it is important to
remember the positives like how much
happiness and companionship that animal
would have brought an aging owner in
their last years of life even someone
younger who dies unexpectedly might have
had their quality of life infinitely
improved by owning a loving pet to make
them smile but on the other hand there's
the negative downside that now some pets
have to live on after a tragic death not
fully understanding where their beloved
owner went so often we hear stories of
dogs that waited for their Master to
come home only for them to never walk
through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the
opposite way and an owner loses their
pet the one silver lining is that we as
human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it
causes we know that eventually despite
how hard it can be to adjust to that
initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to
one day get better but what happens when
someone can't accept the death of their
beloved animal companion when the
unconditional love of their pet is
suddenly missing from their life how far
will a person go to recapture that
feeling how long does it take for grief
born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of
obsession well the answer involves SCP
589 both what it can give and just as
easily take away for as long as she
could remember and even further back
than that that Aaron and her dog Poncho
had been Inseparable ever since her mom
had first adopted that scrappy little
Jack Russell Terrier Aaron had fallen
head over heels in love with that little
rascal loving a pet is different from
loving another person because they just
can't help showing how much they love
you back humans for all their good
qualities are so nuanced and not
everyone is honest with each other all
of the time but a pet especially a dog
even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tale can
easily tell you how they're feeling and
Poncho was no exception Aaron and her
mom Cleo lived alone it was just the two
of them for quite a long time and while
Cleo had little problem with that she
couldn't help but notice how isolating
it was for her daughter from a young age
Aaron had always been quiet kept to
herself at school her mom kept expecting
her to make some friends asked to invite
them over or vice versa but it didn't
seem seemed to be happening it didn't
seem to be bothering her daughter but
Cleo was worried that it was giving her
the wrong idea that being on her own was
somehow better so in an effort to give
Aaron at least one source of
companionship Poncho joined the family
brown patches dotted over his white fur
he was the perfect pet an excitable and
loving little puppy that Aaron was
immediately smitten with when Cleo told
her he was hers to keep being only 7
years old Aaron broke down crying with
tears of joy her mom had let her pick
out a name for him and she'd quickly
settled on Poncho at first Aaron had
meant to say it differently in order to
name the pup after a friendly character
from her favorite animated movie but had
mispronounced it in her excitement at
meeting the energetic dog for the first
time the name quickly stuck though and
as the years went on and Poncho got
bigger Aaron bought her four-legged best
friend a little Poncho of his own to
wear when it started raining over the
the following years Poncho became
Aaron's most constant and loving
companion even as she grew up moving
through her childhood and found making
friends a little easier with every
passing year there never came a time
when she didn't need her best friend
when Aaron had her first breakup in high
school and came home with floods of
Tears In Her Eyes Poncho could sense she
was upset and came wandering up to her
sitting in her lap to make her feel just
a little bit better then a few years
later when her mom got sick Aaron had to
take care of her her a task that would
have been much harder without Poncho
there to alleviate that stress and lift
her and Cleo's spirits and when Cleo
eventually passed the little white and
brown dog sat quietly with his owner as
she said goodbye to her mom now that it
was just the two of them Aaron and
Poncho were living in a tiny apartment
it was cramped for one person and a dog
but Aaron was just grateful to have a
place to live in the company of her
favorite pup besides Poncho wasn't a
puppy anymore in fact he hadn't raced
around the park or chased a ball for
quite a long time with the numerous
stresses of her everyday life least of
all holding down two jobs in her
desperate attempts to make enough money
to pay rent Aaron had hardly noticed the
signs Poncho was showing his age it had
been happening gradually in the
background over the years he wouldn't
chase the ball or really move around
much and when he did it was little more
than a lethargic plot around the
apartment perhaps it was because of such
a measured slower Pac change that Aaron
was unable to acknowledge it she could
see her old friend was getting more
tired sleeping longer his tail rarely
wagging as much as it used to but by now
that felt like Poncho's normal behavior
then again given how important her dog
was to her it's just as likely she
didn't want to accept the truth that
unfortunately nothing lasts forever he
was almost 15 in human years which by
all accounts is an impressive age for a
dog especially one of Poncho's size and
breed it was on a day that Aaron was
outw working her morning job when it
happened the faithful adoring Jack
Russell Terrier who had spent his years
being nothing but loved and giving back
only more love in return curled up on
Aaron's bed the apartment was still
Silent not a sound to be heard save for
those last tired few breaths laying
there maybe the dog wondered if he'd
ever get to see his friend again if she
would make it back from work in time he
closed his little brown eyes and
peacefully drifted off for one last
sleep during the break between her
shifts after the end of the one at her
first job and before starting her second
Aaron had just enough time to get home
usually she had just had enough time to
eat and get herself ready for the
changeover then quickly check on Poncho
before having to dash back out poking
her head into the bedroom she saw her
dog laying right there on her bed there
was a Stillness to him that instantly
made her stomach drop his ears didn't
move when she called his name he didn't
react when she she stroked his fur he
was gone and the moment she realized it
Aaron felt like her whole world had come
crashing down the loss of her oldest and
closest friend hurt almost as much as
losing her mom Aaron always felt that
the problem with funerals wasn't just
how sad they were or how it always
seemed to rain when she went to one
instead it was more that they could
never properly sum up just how much
someone truly meant nobody could ever
condense the years worth of love and
memories into a bur
and it was worse when losing a pet there
was no procession no wake nobody else
there just her and Poncho saying goodbye
a final time eventually things got to be
too much the Heartbreak of Poncho's
death was another struggle in a lifetime
of Lowe's that had all left their
lasting wounds on Aaron that coupled
with the stress of trying to carry on
with a busy life barely able to keep
herself afloat in either of her jobs had
pushed her to the edge of a breakdown
Maybe that's what summoned it perhaps
something had sensed all of Aaron's
mental anguish and had come to seek her
out it might have been that her wishes
for something some little alleviation to
all the pain and stress were finally
being granted or maybe it was just a
gift left by her neighbor the sun had
long since set when Aaron arrived back
at her apartment stepping over the
envelopes that littered her dorat a few
with words like overdue and Urgent
notice printed on them in red ink
passing through the hallway Aaron paused
as she always did hoping to hear the
gentle pattering of Paws against the
floor her therapist had dissuaded her
from doing that saying it would only
make moving on from losing Poncho worse
she didn't care she wanted her dog back
and opening the door to her bedroom it
seemed like someone had been listening
sat on her bed was a stuffed animal
right in the spot where she'd found her
little friend on that horrible day it
had been made to look like a dog
specifically resembling a jack Russell
Terrier with brown patches over its
white fur the plushy was even wearing a
little rain poncho the side of it was
enough to cause Aaron to break down in
tears weeping in heavy sobbs as she
dashed across the bedroom to hold it in
her arms hugging it tightly her tears
seeped into the soft fur as she felt it
against her face she didn't even think
to question where it had even come from
all she wanted to do in that moment was
hold the stuffed animal close for the
first time in what felt like years a
feeling of relief washed over Aaron it
was as if everything was melting away
the stress of work and the toll of her
tiring shifts gone all the pain from
losing Cleo and Poncho dissipated too in
fact it felt like she now had her
beloved dog back no it was better than
that it was almost as though everything
about Poncho his energy his Spirit the
way he made her feel so calm and loved
was all distilled into this stuffed
animal and now now it would never grow
old never age and die causing her more
pain Aaron gripped the soft toy tightly
the longer she held the hug for the more
her stress and sadness faded her face
was still wet with tears although her
sobbing had gradually become low gentle
Chuckles soon giving way to a peel of
uncontrollable laughter rising in volume
it was as though she had taken something
and the Very chemistry of her brain was
being altered but after so much hardship
it felt good to the point where she was
almost light-headed laying down on the
floor of her bedroom arms locked around
the plushy that reminded her so much of
Poncho Aaron continued softly giggling
to herself her entire body relaxed so
much so that every part of her felt like
warm butter as if she was about to start
melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't
have even cared her dopamine levels were
spiking flooding her with the bodily
hormone that relieves stress and makes a
person feel good in in fact right now
she was feeling better than she ever had
every day that followed Aaron would come
home to her stuffed animal her Poncho 2
as she liked to think of it it didn't
bother her how childlike anyone else
might find it for a grown woman to rely
so heavily on a plushy for Comfort at
any rate it wasn't something she was
advertising to anyone else after every
shift at both of her jobs she'd race
back to her apartment right to Poncho 2
and just sit there just basking in the
way it made her feel it was the most
all-encompassing sense of euphoria and
relief reducing her stress so much that
she felt like she was floating her body
lighter than air that feeling was all
that mattered to her some days she
wouldn't even eat Poncho 2 was more
important to her than food gradually she
started to become addicted to that
feeling having to wait until the end of
her work shifts to feel that Rush of
happy chemicals flood her brain was too
long of a delay she started to Crave it
while working unable to focus feeling
erratic and Restless without Poncho too
of course she couldn't risk bringing it
to work with her what if someone took it
or she dropped it her boss might see her
with a stuffed animal at her desk and
fire her on the spot or think that she
was absolutely crazy the only safe place
for her source of relief was at home but
Aon knew she needed something to bridge
the gap while she was working the only
substitute that worked was taking a
photo of Poncho 2 on her phone then
blowing it up and printing off a copy
Aaron could carry it around portably
keeping it in her pocket and taking it
out to look at it every few minutes
while she worked the hid of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as
strong as getting to hold her stuffed
animal after all it was just a grainy
photo from her phone essentially acting
like a patch to tide her over until she
could get back home to the real thing
however it didn't take long for Aon to
start taking Poncho with her anywhere
that wasn't work to the grocery store to
visit her mom and her dog and of course
to therapy I'm rather concerned about
this pattern of behavior Aon
psychotherapist Dr Lee stated when her
patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite
side of her office on a leather couch
Aaron had Poncho 2 pressed tightly
against her I don't care she sighed her
brain already a wash with hormones that
kept her calm I like how it makes me
feel so I don't care Aaron look at
yourself Dr Lee urged you aren't
properly dealing with your grief it
seems to me you're channeling all your
desire for positive emotion into this
stuffed animal Poncho too Aon corrected
her without taking her eyes off the soft
brown and white dog and its little cloak
listen to me the therapist insisted
trying desperately to get through to her
Poncho your dog your real dog is gone
you lost him 6 months ago and your mom
Cleo she passed away too you have to
process and come to terms with those
things as sad as they might make you
feel that's how we move on but what
you're doing right now isn't healthy
Aaron it's becoming an obsession Turning
Away Aaron pressed Poncho 2 up against
her face I don't care she repeated by
now Aaron had become fully dependent on
Poncho 2 showing up late for both jobs
just so she could spend longer feeling
those endorphins and hormones that
hugging the stuffed animal seemed to
bring it didn't take long for her to
start skipping entire shifts for days at
a time and canceling any and all other
plans just to sit at home basking in the
relief brought on by her apparent
Obsession her apartment became a mess
untied piles of mail by the front door
the walls plastered with hundreds of
photos of her stuffed animal fueling her
Obsession her evening job was the first
to fire Aaron citing her recent absences
as the grounds for her dismissal even
then she still didn't seem to care the
fact she might not be able to make rent
barely registered returning home after
her other job called her in to tell Aon
she would no longer be working there
either she instantly looked around for
Poncho 2 but it was nowhere to be found
all the photos on the walls having faded
Aaron checked her phone all the original
copies of the pictures were gone too
instantly racked with fear so addicted
to the plushy that she could barely
function without it she began tearing
her apartment to shreds looking for it
she wrenched cupboards off their hinges
and tipped over her refrigerator
flipping her mattress Aaron sliced the
fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for Poncho 2 but
unable to find it anywhere she became
frantic erratic pulling her hair out in
a fit of uncontrollable despair where
had it gone had someone stolen it Dr Lee
the paranoia had already set in
convincing Aaron that her therapist must
have taken Poncho too she was the only
other person who knew about it and had
been so critical of her using it to make
herself feel better marching into Dr
Lee's office utterly enraged Beyond
Reason all Aon could could think about
was getting her stuffed animal back no
matter what she had to do the effect it
had on her was so powerful so potent and
addictive that living without it was
worth anything even another person's
life little did Aaron realize as her
hands grew wetter coated with more of Dr
Lee's blood after every bludgeoning
strike her therapist had no idea where
Poncho 2 was in fact she had nothing to
do with it Vanishing in the first place
it had disappeared all on its own along
with all the photograph copies Aaron had
printed arriving somewhere miles away
SCP 589 was ready to begin the whole
cycle again on its next victim it would
take on whatever shape it needed to
appease the desires of the very next
person to find it praying on their
vulnerability and making them totally
dependent on it that was what it did
everywhere it went leeching off people
that it could easily manipulate its
presence and interaction would calm SCP
589 victims helping to alleviate their
stress or make them feel better about
their deepest
insecurities before long these helpless
victims would be able to think of
nothing else feeling as if they were
unable to live without their Obsession
doll and every time that was when SCP
589 would make its
cruestv leaving its prey in a state of
intense withdrawal with a calming
influence of SCP 589 absent from their
lives all of a sudden the infected
people would suffer from a variety of
potential psychological symptoms manic
depression psychosis uncontrollable
despair Dementia or an errands case
paranoia and a heightened sense of
aggression that caused her to murder Dr
Lee that was one of the earliest in a
Spate of similar incidents that had been
reported as SCP 589 traveled from town
to town its influence spread leaving
entire populations dead in its wake all
the while the stuffed animal fed on the
mental anguish that had caused its
victims making them pay the ultimate
price for their Obsession in the
aftermath of the disastrous Exxon Valdes
oil spill of
1989 the SCP Foundation received a tip
about some anomalous plant life
surrounding the affected area plants
there were beginning to mutate and
change for seemingly no reason with
concerns about pollution on everyone's
mind it seemed possible that the plant
life had been directly affect Ed by the
oil spill itself after all Humanity's
destructive impact on the earth had
already become noticeable even decades
ago however when the foundation showed
up to investigate they found something
much stranger all of the mutated plants
had a common substance on them in their
pollen seeds roots or the surrounding
soil and we're not talking about the
millions of gallons of spilled crude oil
no one had ever seen this substance
before and all tests on it proved
inconclusive they collected samples of
it and began extensive studies on what
would become known as SCP 1100 though
SCP 1100 was initially classified as
safe in the foundation records it would
quickly reveal itself to be anything but
the first entry in SCP 1100s official
file described it as a complex organic
substance that causes anomalous
transformations in natural plant life it
can be transmitted between plants by way
of pollen and seeds within 72 hours an
infected plant becomes dangerous or
hostile to human life during testing
Foundation researchers exposed a variety
of edible plants to SC SCP 1100
artificially pollinating the plants with
samples of the compound Tomatoes apples
strawberries carrots and cabbage were
among the plants tested as the fruits
and vegetables ripened many visual
differences became apparent right away
the skin of the tomatoes thickened and
darkened into an off-putting leathery
Brown until it was incredibly difficult
to bite through or even even slice into
with a knife when the tomatoes were
finally cut into pieces the flesh was
coarse and dry the Cabbage took on the
appearance of rotten food growing a fine
layer of mold as the leaves became slick
and oily the strawberri sprouted
incredibly sharp Thorns where ordinary
strawberri simply had seeds becoming
unsafe to eat the carrots and apples
were visibly unchanged but had some
unfortunate side effects when fed to
d-class Personnel at the site the
carrots induced nearly instantaneous
vomiting and dizziness triggering a
seizure in one particularly unfortunate
subject the apples on the other hand had
developed hard sharp structures near the
core much like the classic urban legend
of the razor blade hidden in the
Halloween Apple Personnel Who sampled
the fruit suffered lacerations to their
gums tongue and roof of the mouth
whether through disgusting appearance
tougher skin and Thorns or harmful side
effects all of the plants were rendered
completely inedible initial containment
procedures were not not terribly strict
SCP 1100 was kept within the secure
biohazardous material storage unit at
biocontainment site 33 this seemed to
adequately contain the substance until
one day during a bit of routine
scientific testing a large amount of SCP
1100 was gathered for experimentation
when out of nowhere it vaporized
disappearing into the air not only did
it contaminate the plant life
specifically set aside for the
experiment but it traveled through the
vents and infected all the plant life
being grown at the site specifics of the
incident have been redacted from the
record but 70% of the on-site Personnel
were killed in this Containment Breach
in the aftermath the remainder of SCP
1100 was moved to biocontainment site 26
the object's class formerly listed as
safe was upgraded to uid after it was
transferred to site 26 experimentation
with SCP 1100 resumed after being
exposed to the substance this new round
of plants transformed in a variety of
ways within 48 hours with increasingly
disturbing results a mango tree
underwent a chemical transformation the
fruit previously ripe and fragrant
became filled with highly corrosive acid
when touched the transformed mangoes
would burst spraying this custic liquid
all over the person who touched them
long Vines of common Ivy developed
muscle-like internal structures one poor
declass made the mistake of putting his
hand a bit too close to an infected ivy
plant only to have it wrap around his
hand and crushed the bone into powder
before he could get away a rose Bush's
Thorns elongated hardening and
sharpening to the point comparable to a
knife another rose bush excreted a toxic
substance from its thorns that when
tested was found to be similar to the
type of neurotoxin found in the deadly
cone snail as these experiments
continued at site 26 several of the
researchers assigned to a cp100 noticed
that it would become increasingly
dangerous to contain and that its
effects were becoming stronger more
pronounced and taking effect much more
quickly at this point no Source could be
found for the substance though a theory
was posited by Dr Smith that it was the
creation of a radical environmentalist
group with access to resources and
Technology on the same level as the
foundation a task force was put together
to monitor environmentalist groups
around the globe for possible hints
about the creator of SCP 1100 during the
course of the experiments at site 26 SC
SCP 1100 vaporized spontaneous again it
spread throughout the office in record
time wiping out 96% of the on-site
Personnel at that point in a desperate
attempt to stop the infection from
spreading to the other sites or even
into the civilian World a research
assistant made the choice to detonate
the on-site nuclear warhead the
infection was stopped but all remaining
surviving Personnel were killed in the
blast and the surrounding area Afflicted
with irreparable damage SCP 1100 was
moved to a triple redundant hermetically
sealed container stored in a containment
chamber at an unlisted Foundation site
the container is checked daily to ensure
that it is still completely intact and
able to hold the substance if anything
should happen to The Container as cp100
is to be immediately transferred to a
new one after the devastating loss of
site 26 and additional experimentation
SCP 1100 class was changed from uclid to
ker this allowed the foundation to
allocate additional resources to its
containment seeing as safe and uclid
containment procedures had both resulted
in catastrophic loss of human life and
in both instances they had been
profoundly lucky that it hadn't been
worse after determining that exposure to
SCP 1100 would make edible plants unfit
for consumption and heighten the danger
of otherwise normally innocuous plants
the foundation became curious about the
effects the substance might have on
animal test subjects a variety of
species were selected for the animal
trials including deer mice cows chickens
cats and dogs the deer and the mice both
ordinarily considered to be docile prey
animals in the wild were the first to be
exposed to SCP 1100 within 24 hours they
had become much stronger and more
aggressive one of the deer was able to
break down the door of an observation
room by ramming against it with its head
once it had broken out of the room it
proceeded to charge and attack any
person that had saw the mice became
prone to swarming researchers and biting
them wherever they could with jaw
strength capable of biting through
hazmat suits and even biting one
person's finger clean off any attempts
to subdue the animals were futile the
creatur somehow fighting off even the
strongest sedative the only way to
prevent the infected deer and mice from
continuing to attack was to terminate
them next the cows and chickens were
exposed to SCP 1100 they did not display
any behavioral changes once exposed nor
did they show any increased strength the
cows and chickens continued to behave
Norm normally going about their days as
if nothing had changed they did not
respond to the presence of humans with
the exception of feeding times during
which they would approach only to eat
their food a selection of the livestock
were slaughtered in order to perform an
autopsy and look for anomalies in their
bodies everything looked unchanged until
some of the meat was prepared for
consumption and given to a selection of
d-class personnel the beef taken from
the infected cows was impossible to
digest causing a dramatic amount of
gastric upset cramping and vomiting
testing showed that inexplicably it had
no identifiable nutritional value the
chicken on the other hand became highly
toxic showing lethal levels of Cyanide
and arsenic naturally present in its
flesh when tested like with the fruits
and vegetables exposure to SCP 1100 made
the cows and chickens impossible for
human beings to eat the cats and dogs
were the last to be experimented on no
matter how doile and friendly the
animals were at first within 24 hours
they had become vicious at the sight of
any human they would attempt to attack
like the de and mice they could not be
subdued by any level of sedative
displaying shocking levels of strength
and resilience for their size one
d-class lost his arm and another had his
eyes clawed out before the subjects
could be terminated whatever SCP 1100
was it made everything it touched
dangerous to humans even Man's Best
Friend could be convinced to turn on him
in only a single day as might have been
expected given the significant loss of
life and the destruction of two
different Foundation sites
experimentation with SCP 1100 has been
suspended until further notice the
substance went from affecting plants and
animals within 72 hours to accomplishing
it in 48 and then 24 it is becoming more
efficient and more dangerous if allowed
to continue adapting it could someday
transform infected organisms in only a
minute if the substance ever escapes
containment again defoliant and desant
are to be deployed within a 1 km radius
of the infected area and the area must
be quarantined for 12 months if the
situation becomes dire enough nuclear or
chemical weapons may be deployed in
order to distract the public and provide
an acceptable explanation for the
quarantine how had things gone so
horribly wrong so fast bits of
surveillance video were recovered from
the ruins of site 26 providing a glimpse
into what exactly happened before the
entire site was destroyed the footage
pieced together is not entirely
inclusive but here's what we know for
sure a foundation researcher referred to
as Dr V disarmed and shot the armed
guard at the entrance to SCP 1100s
Containment facility while he did this
another Foundation researcher known as
Dr M entered the containment and took
the sample of SCP 1100 out the footage
cuts off for a while here but it becomes
clear when the video resumes that Dr V
and Dr M dumped part of the sample into
the site's water supply and vaporized
the rest of it into the air this this is
believed to be the cause of the mass
contamination that occurred at the site
which was previously thought to have
been accidental Dr V and Dr M were later
linked to an environmentalist
organization on the foundation's watch
list during the investigation of Dr V
and Dr m a diary was discovered from Dr
V's home in it he wrote about his
personal theories regarding SCP 1100 and
where it might have come from while his
colleagues proposed SCP 1100 was some
sort of deliberately engineered
bioweapon Dr V believed it to have a far
more organic point of origin he stated
plainly it's a planetary immune response
it's Gaia Mother Earth fighting back
against us the more we try to fight it
the worse it gets she wants us all dead
wants us gone because of what we've done
to her and there's nothing we can do to
stop it he concluded the entry with the
assertion that the only thing Humanity
can do now is accept the punishment the
Earth wishes to give us this was his his
final entry before he and Dr M triggered
the destruction of site 26 were the
doctors right should we just accept that
the Earth is done with humanity and
ready to drive us to Extinction before
we can do any further damage the jury's
still out on that perhaps we can turn
back the clock mitigate the harm done to
the natural world and attempt to earn
back its favor before it's too late but
if SCP 1100 ever makes its way out of
containment and reaches the plants and
animals of our world world turning them
all against us one by one we won't have
much of a choice when you think of the
biggest most moneymaking merchandised
and capitalized game series of all time
there's only one franchise that comes to
mind Pokémon for the entirety of its
lifespan Pokemon has been a financial
Powerhouse and every year the series
seems to grow in popularity and revenue
whether it's games cards a show toys or
even po Pokemon branded clothes that you
need you'll have no difficulty finding a
product that appeals to you everyone
knows Pikachu's face and nearly every
child born within the past 20 years has
had a firsthand experience with Pokémon
it is in some respects inescapable if
you hate Pokémon too bad because this
little electric Mouse runs the world and
you'll just have to sit back and deal
with it one could even say that Pokémon
is uncontainable which poses quite the
issue for the SCP Foundation who work
tirelessly to ensure that no facet of
life is withheld from its reach but the
foundation rarely deals with major
franchises beloved by millions upon
millions of people across the world and
for good reason too an anomaly tied in
with a major franchise poses a lot of
problems on the containment side namely
its ability to spread uncontrollably and
without care being witnessed by
countless individuals before the
foundation comes up with with a way to
contain it Global supply lines have to
be interrupted to prevent anomalous
products from hitting shelves corporate
Espionage committed and most of all a
massively expensive coverup operation to
remove said products from consumers
hands if the foundation had to deal with
an anomaly affecting the Pokémon
franchise there's no telling how out of
hand it would get before they'd be able
to get a handle on the situation but in
2019 that's exactly what happened today
we're going to be looking at SCP
5254 an anomaly dubbed got to catch them
all in the foundation's database the
year was 2019 the place Japan the home
country of the Pokémon franchise every
year since 2014 the Pokémon company has
held a festival named Pikachu outbreak
in the city of Yokohama in which
hundreds of costumed actors dressed as
Pikachu would crowd the city's Mirai
district and perform dance and even
participate in a a parade the event was
intended to celebrate the Pokémon
franchise and promote whatever the
latest Venture the series is pushing
whether it's a game a movie or something
else the festival proved to be
successful and has been held every year
since after all who wouldn't want to see
a legion of Pikachu running a Muk
through the streets but the fun would be
shortlived during the 2019 outbreak
where something incredibly unusual
occurred picture this a large crowd
hundreds of fans in Pokémon themed
attire standing on both sides of the
streets men women children anyone and
everyone came to see the Pikachu
outbreak and they weren't disappointed
parading down the street was a horde of
Pikachu just as advertised they danced
bounced and walked together in routine
fashion all while the crowd cheered and
yelled even the spectators in the crowd
showed their spirit with Pikachu themed
hats yellow Tails fastened to their
backs and yellow face mask masks with
two electrified red circles on the
cheeks the parade proceeded as normal
that is until one of the parading
Pikachu started behaving oddly it began
as out of sync movements strange wobbles
and deviations from the parade path for
the heavily coordinated outbreak
Festival this was unusual the rest of
the Pikachu line danced to the Beat of
the Music sticking in formation as best
as they could then as if pushed by an
invisible force the strange Pikachu
raced forward diving head first into the
crowd barreling into the group of people
and eventually colliding the crowd moved
out of the way slightly shocked no pun
intended by what had occurred but then
it happened again two more Pikachu ran
into the crowd and then again over 15
Pikachu ran themselves into the crowd
resulting in a massive disruption of the
parade and the shutdown of the event
entirely the foundation quickly caught
wind of this and sent their closest
operatives to assess the situation ation
in a controlled Fashion After blocking
off the crowd and shutting down the
event another strange detail emerged one
that ensured the foundation that there
had been some sort of anomalous
significance to what was occurring here
some of the crowd members involved in
the collisions were suffering very
peculiar medical injuries namely blunt
force trauma way stronger than what a
clash with a costumed actor would induce
and severe electrical burns the
foundation was positive there was
something occurring here and with a
franchise as vast and popular as Pokémon
they didn't want to take any chances
immediately Foundation agents began
collecting information on the event
setting up probes in the offices of game
freak and the Pokémon company and
attempting to get to the bottom of what
exactly happened during the parade when
the foundation interrogated the 15
mascots who collided with the crowd they
were shocked to learn that they weren't
mascots at all but instead fully
separate entities that resembled the
Pikachu costume x-rays revealed that
their once human skeletons were now
fused to their costumes and touching
them produced a minor electric shock the
performers had become Pikachu and now
they were unable to be removed from
their costumes every captured instance
had expired before the foundation was
able to fully study and discern what was
occurring to them their bodies unable to
support themselves after such a lethal
extreme transformation later observation
found that the synthetic components of
the costumes such as the cotton and
plastic composits had fused into their
flesh and muscle tissue bodily fluids
were found to contain foreign DNA and
numerous strange structures to the point
where an ordinary human's genetic makeup
would be incomparable and unrecognizable
with that affected by the anomaly the
foundation tentatively opened a file on
SCP
5254 the anomalous transformation of a
human into the rough approximation of a
Pokémon character and began carrying out
tests to to determine what occurred
during the festival what caused SCP 5254
to manifest it couldn't have been random
could it the foundation needed to know
one theory that the researchers working
on the SCP 5254 file had come up with
was that it was the large Gathering of
Pokémon related clothing worn by the
crowd that prompted the transformation
but that begged the question why hadn't
this occurred at any previous festivals
or large Pokémon related Gatherings it
was a huge franchise there were
absolutely more events that had masses
of costume fans Dawning Pokémon related
gear did something happen in recent
years to Manifest this anomaly the only
way to find out was to conduct testing
in one of the easier experiments that a
d-class Personnel was tasked with
carrying out the foundation ordered a
group of them to dress entirely in
Pokémon related clothing which the
foundation provided themselves some
items such as a full-bodied gavor onesie
were taken from Dr clef's Personal
Collection itself no he is not taking
further questions anyways with the
d-class looking utterly ridiculous in
full Pokémon get up the observing
researchers began their tests first was
a d-class outfitted solely in a Pokémon
Pikachu big face with ears hat as the
product's official title stated after
standing there for 15 minutes the
foundation determined that there was no
discernable effect next was a Pokémon
detective Pikachu cosplay mask latex
which the foundation placed on the same
d-class after another 15 minutes with no
changes observed the d-class closed the
experiment remarking that it was stupid
the research team told the d-class to
remain composed and to just continue
along with the trials unless they wanted
to be reprimanded after that was a Deon
adult onesie Pikachu animal pajamas a
few researchers held back laughter as
the hardened muscular declass in front
of them stood around in a Pikachu onzy
that barely fit him after asking him how
he was feeling the subject quickly
turned aggressive the results from this
test were deemed inconclusive due to
researchers being unable to determine if
the quick snap in Anger was as a result
of a potential anomaly or whether the
d-class was just getting fed up with
having to do this in my opinion this
test was hilarious for the next test two
DCL classes were brought in clad in
Pikachu onesies the d-class were placed
4 M apart after a period of time a
tingling sensation was reported in the
arms and legs akin to that pins and need
feeling you get when your arms fall
asleep or when you get shocked by static
electricity the next one had four D
classes all dressed similar to the
previous group instead of being meters
apart they were asked to hold hands
which the DCL classes begrudgingly did
severe migraines were reported as well
as throbbing pain in the cranium and
lower jaws of the face near the tailbone
some DCL classes reported a dull aching
most curiously several areas on their
body had begun to change in skin
coloration namely a mustard yellow
eventually the foundation began to test
for an affiliation or emotional
connection to the Pokémon franchise
could that be the key to understanding
SCP
5254 another 4 DCL class all noted
Pokémon fans were brought in one had
owned a copy of Pokémon Yellow for the
Game Boy when he was a child and another
had a high-leveled account on the
Pokémon Go app the foundation discovered
that these d-class reported muscle
spasms along the extent of their spines
with one complaining of tightness in
their chest before coughing up toughs of
fur and another physically recoiling
upon an attempt at physical contact in
fear they would electrically shock the
researcher these experiments Pro to be
fruitful for the foundation as they
learned that SCP 5254 was irreversible
removing the clothing or items did not
result in the transformative properties
of SCP 5254 reversing furthermore the
test in went on Beyond this point just
to cover all possible bases of what SCP
5254 was before the details were
properly ironed out a total of 56
d-class Personnel were lost during these
experiments and testing paused due to
concern by Foundation higher-ups of a
potential security breach and damage
being done to the site's power grid but
most importantly a connection to the
Pokémon brand was what enabled SCP 5254
to truly take effect that that's what
occurred at the outbreak festival with
the bodies of costume Pikachu Fanatics
fused into their costumes and barreled
towards the crowd now that the
foundation understood the how of SCP
5254 they still had to get to the why
even by Foundation standards this is a
pretty odd and random anomaly did the
answers lie with game freak or the
Pokémon company itself after the
festival incident the foundation put web
probes into the servers of the Pokémon
company comp's Japanese branch and had
their webcrawlers scan through millions
of Correspondence emails to find any
hint of unusual behavior a series of
emails between major shareholders in the
company were found the first was from
kimishima Tatsumi the CEO of Nintendo
the overseeing company above the Pokémon
company and sunuk Kazu ishihara the
latter's CEO do not ask questions if
this sirv Viper wants Manpower for his
project give it to him our society will
not mess with these irrelevant
individuals he whoever he claims to be
may be charging us a small fortune but
at least he seems genuinely interested
in bringing our Creations to life
bringing their Creations to life how
curious the email was dated to 2017 2
years before the outbreak incident the
foundation decided to dig deeper another
email from 2017 exchanged between the
two individuals months after the first
Tuesday will Mark the fifth visit by by
the Fukushima orphanage to our
headquarters I told the Press it's part
of our Global Outreach program to spread
the joy of Pokémon to the rest of the
world early results have been positive I
should have a specimen to show you the
next time we meet in Tokyo your daughter
likes Eevee yes it seemed like these
Executives were talking about creating
real Pokémon somehow what did the
orphanage have to do with this another
email read play anytime anywhere with
anyone yes the slogan for the switch is
very app for what we're trying to
accomplish your marketing team deserves
a raise I'm pleased to report Pokémon go
has it 750 million unique downloads in
July and 5 million daily average users
this past week the popularity of the
franchise continues to grow think of the
possibilities once we integrate
augmented reality AR technology into the
project alaria as a clean and efficient
form of air transportation Charizard
serving in the self-defense forces and
yes Pikachu makes making our Reliance on
nuclear energy a thing of the past soon
Pokémon will come to life before our
very eyes the foundation couldn't
believe something as absurd as creating
real Pokémon was a genuine possibility
for these companies it was going on
right beneath their noses but the emails
from 2018 began to show cracks in the
Pokémon company and Nintendo's plans the
accidents are growing in number are you
sure sir viiper has everything under
control we cannot hide these incidents
from the public for forever we already
have our hands full trying to catch The
Runaways if we don't take action soon
more people will get hurt or Worse the
Pokémon brand will be tarnished forever
whoever was responsible for creating
Pokémon for the companies was going by
the alius of Sir Viper and it seemed
like their experiments weren't working
the way they planned an email directly
addressed to Sir Viper fully
encapsulated the Pokémon company's
disgust at the individual once they
realized the experiments weren't
succeeding in in creating an immersive
fun Pokémon experience in the real world
you promised us Pokémon as pets and
companions not these mutations I've had
to recall thousands of faulty
merchandise with tens of thousands of
defective products still circulating the
market just what kind of sorcery have
you forced Upon Our Hands the government
is breathing down my neck Tatsumi son
has had to resign and I'm starting to
hear about this Foundation poking around
tell me the truth is there any way to
reverse the effects or have you doomed
us all sir Viper 1995 as their screen
name read responded with this I don't
know what to tell you I've given the
people what they want only true fans
will get a Pokemon of their own your
company was the very best at building
your brand congratulations today Pokémon
has taken over our hearts and Minds
perhaps one day we will see them take
over the world and with that the company
had cut off all communication with Sur
viiper but now the foundation had to get
to the bottom of what was happening in
these boardrooms and offices making
Pokémon in real life it sounded crazy
and from the way the emails were worded
they had apparently succeeded in making
something even if they considered it a
failure 3 months later after all of the
research on SCP 5254 was conducted the
overseer Council authorized a raid on
the Pokemon company offices in monado
City Tokyo on June 16th 2019 from the
way the emails were written they had
reason to believe that civilians were
potentially being held against their
will and used in these experiments
failure to deal with them now could
potentially spell disaster if they got
out and the cause of SCP 5254 wasn't
immediately neutralized following the
Japanese government's authorization of
the raid a foundation mobile task force
Detachment from Epsilon 11 nine-tailed
fox was stationed outside the offices
the task force broke into the building
building through the fire exit and
promptly cleared out tourists and
civilians from the area during the raid
they encountered a large creature that
resembled the Charizard an orange fire
breathing dragon Pokémon that stopped
them in their tracks in the hallway
wings and elongated snout the perfect
color it looked exactly as if a
Charizard had left from the screen and
into real life it spewed combustible
orange liquid at the team but they
quickly dispatched it with ease using
their weapons to put some water on the
Pokémon's fire well the water was
actually a salvo of bullets but the
metaphor still works most of the
building was cleared and those inside
detained for further questioning but
then the team came to a set of steel
doors inside was a room littered with
toys brightly colored walls and large
metal cages inside the cages were some
of the most disgusting Creations the
team had ever witnessed Sur vipers
failed experiments clearly entities at
various stages of SCP 5254
transformation one resembled a Vulpix a
fox Pokémon it had engorged eye sockets
and blood flowing down their cheeks
another cage had a boy with cheekbones
protruding high and sideways pulling
thin skin over the rest of his face
another had a large bear-like entity
with serrated claws with alternate
fingers peeling and decomposing
underneath most horrifying of all were a
pair inside cages near the other side of
the room a girl with an extended
flattened in gorg tongue which pulled
drool onto the floor at her feet she was
made to resemble a lick tongue a Pokémon
with a similarly large tongue another
was an elongated purple snake like the
Pokémon Arbok except its head was that
of a toddler it rides back and forth
balling and screaming the team requested
immediate medical pickup to remove the
specimens from the room wherever sir
Viper the individual responsible for
this was the foundation could not locate
them the foundation contained the
experiments and detained Mr ishihara the
CEO of the company he was brought back
to the research site for an interview
isihara claimed not to know of the
experiment's existence but he quickly
broke down when asked about Sir Viper
ishihara had this to say we didn't ask
too many questions when we found out
what he had been doing to the children
we terminated his contract immediately
but the damage had been done later we
discovered he had already tampered with
our production lines and distribution
infrastructure at this point it's
impossible to tell which products had
been affected on the market following
This Global coordination between
Nintendo the foundation and the Pokémon
company in an attempt to figure out a
solution to products that were affected
by SCP 5254 is presently ongoing all
attempts to contact Sur viiper 1995's
email result in the same automated
message Happy Hunting but even you can't
catch them all now go watch SCP 3108 the
nerfing gun and SCP 387 the living Lego
for more kid-friendly franchises Twisted
into anomalous entities contained by the
SCP Foundation